foreign
marketing has become an integral part of
businesses to attract and retain their
target audience it involves creating
valuable and engaging content to drive
profitable customer action content can
come in many forms such as blog posts
videos social media posts Etc the demand
for Content marketing professionals is
rapidly increasing making it a promising
career choice a Content marketing
manager can make an average of 68 000
annually and a Content marketing
strategist can earn an average salary of
sixty five thousand dollars annually to
succeed in content marketing you need
excellent writing skills creativity and
a deep understanding of your target
audience content marketing may be a
great career choice if you possess these
skills and are interested in marketing
with a promising future and competitive
salaries content marketing is an
exciting industry to pursue now let me
tell you about simply lens postgraduate
program in digital marketing created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint with this program you
will learn everything from the
fundamentals of digital marketing to the
latest trends and techniques used by Top
Market as worldwide you will explore SEO
sem content marketing social media
marketing email marketing and more this
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world if you're
looking to jump start your career in
digital marketing or take your skills to
the next level then simply learns
professional certificate program in
digital marketing is the perfect place
to start to learn more about the course
you can click the link in the
description box below now let's check
out what we have installed for you in
this content marketing full course we
will start a discussion with what
content marketing is then we will
discuss various content marketing
strategies post that will learn some
techniques on how to write content then
we will check out an important tool
called Google Keyword Planner then we
will dive into a discussion on how to
start a blog and what blogging means for
a beginner after that we will help you
set up your WordPress account for your
blog following that we will discuss
content marketing return on investment
finally we'll wrap up this content and
marketing full course with some
interview questions on content marketing
I'm Greg charpo and what is that I mean
what we're going to talk about in this
first module of a Content marketing
Foundation course is literally content
marketing uh okay what is it so content
marketing Is Not A New Concept it's been
around for over a hundred years in fact
one of the classic Foundation stories of
you know the birth of content marketing
goes all the way back to the Michelin
Brothers in France and the Michelin
Brothers you know in case you haven't
done your history that's okay you know a
little refresher right now
were two brothers who made pneumatic
tires and they were trying to sell them
along with an Innovative product at its
time called the automobile
in an era where the roads were horrible
in a place France where frankly people
didn't like to get outside of Paris and
into uh provinces because my God what
was worth going out there for you know
or Paris that's all Happening Here
and what the Michelin Brothers realized
is if they wanted to sell more tires
they had to get people to drive farther
and farther
and use them
so what did they come up with
the concept that really is the birth of
content Marketing in my book
was the Michelin guide
and the Michelin guide was unique in
that it reviewed restaurants not just
restaurants nearby in Paris but
restaurants out there in the provinces
and the Michelin brothers are the ones
who came up with the one two and three
star rating system to say this
restaurant I know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads but guess what
to die for the Ratatouille oh you you
gotta have it this is a three-star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip
and oh by the way and since we're going
to give you a guide and you have to get
out of Paris in order to get there we're
going to tell you where you can find
gasoline along the way uh which hotels
uh you might want to stay at overnight
and oh by the way just in case you have
to
how to repair a flat tire particularly
if it's a Michelin tire because it's a
Pneumatic and you know what it's quite
easy to repair
and guess what that put Michelin on the
map why they weren't trying to sell you
more tires
they weren't telling you about the
features and benefits of round
or tire repair I mean that was in there
but it was only a how-to article not
necessarily a feature and benefit
what they were doing was they were
speaking to Their audience about what
Their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in 1900
was food
and by creating content
that got the audience to get into their
new Innovative automobile and drive all
the way out there into the provinces for
that absolutely remarkable three-star
restaurant
people got more Flats people had to
replace their tires but it was worth it
and oh by the way
Michelin sold my tires
so that that's a great story every time
you sort of
you know hit a pause and like well we
were doing content marketing and we need
to come up with a concept
back to the Michelin guide it's it's
great Foundation
so let's go
to a modern definition where are we now
in the 21st century
when it comes to content marketing
well you can read the slide here and
read the definition and some people like
reading definitions I'm not going to
read it to you but I am going to
highlight a couple of words in the
definition that I think are absolutely
critical to any definition
of content marketing
the content that you create needs to be
relevant
and it also has to be valuable
now if it's not relevant then you're not
actually meeting my needs or interests
you know and why would I be interested
in them and we've gotten way too tired
of screening out the commercial that
comes on
um you know trying to sell out snow
tires
and pardon me we live in Florida
I don't use the tires what the what the
heck is this commercial doing
you know interrupting what I'm watching
so relevance is important relevance
means that this content isn't going to
get screened out
and the valuable the valuable can can
work in a lot of different ways it can
be interesting
it can be useful
you know value is an interesting
proposition all by itself
but that's the key to content marketing
uh it's not just creating more spam
it's not just throwing more trash over
the fence and hoping something happens
this is something where if you've
created valuable and relevant content
you know what your customers will find
you that's a whole different kind of
proposition
I know there's some Skeptics who are
saying oh come on come on come on
content marketing is just a fancy new
name for social media marketing right
and the answer is well there is some
overlap and we're going to deal with
that in module three
but let me just be clear here
social media content is part of what
content marketing needs to create
but it can also create content for your
website and that's not the social media
it can also create content that your PR
people can share with
reporters or bloggers and that's not
normally considered social media content
and by the way all of that content can
be optimized so maybe it actually is
part of SEO not social media marketing
in fact that's the other place that
content marketing really overlaps
and it's not coincidental
it so happens that around February 2011
when Google rolled out the first of its
multiple versions of the panda update
all of a sudden even seos started to pay
attention to content marketing why
because Google changed the rules and
what Google basically said is if your
content isn't valuable or relevant
you know what it's not going to rank
very well in our search animal who are
them
and all of a sudden people who had been
used to like putting keywords in the
right places
realized content matters I mean I've got
to actually tell stories that are
interesting I've got to create
information that's valuable uh
yeah you can make it relevant that's the
optimization part
but you know if you're trying to
optimize a piece of boring irrelevant
trash
God bless you good luck
so yeah content marketing
has grown it's like tripled in terms of
web search interest since the panda
update
and then we're talking about panda one
of course there was Panda 2 Panda 3
Panda 4. I mean come on
Google is driving us in this direction
and so content marketing is pretty
relevant today
now one of the other things that people
in content marketing struggle with is oh
but you don't understand I do B2B
content marketing or I'm a small
business or pardon me I'm an Enterprise
and so content marketing has to come in
flavors right
well possibly maybe on occasion
so let's just question that assumption
for a second
you know content marketing has been
around now long enough and enough people
have done it but some research has been
conducted
and it's been conducted against b2c
marketers and B2B marketers and small
business marketers and Enterprise level
marketers
and when they start asking key questions
like okay
we're going to try to determine what is
the difference between an effective
content marketer and an ineffective
content marketer
let's see the results
well first of all
the most important thing to Be an
Effective b2c content marketer
is you need a documented content
strategy
oh okay all right I mean people who are
winging it aren't as effective as people
who actually have thought about this and
written it down got it okay
no great Insight but you know
interesting to note
secondly they've got to have somebody in
charge who oversees content marketing
oh Lord does that mean we have to have a
reorg or maybe we just have to designate
somebody who reports to somebody else
whatever but guess what it really helps
if somebody is driving this process
third they've got to be using more
content marketing tactics than their
less effective peers
and this is not an argument more is
better this is just pardon me that's the
way the data falls out the people who
are actually more effective are doing
more different kinds of things
a broader range of tactics
and who knows maybe it's that broader
range that's part of the success formula
same thing is true with social media
platforms
the effective content marketers are
using more than the ineffective ones
and last but not least and this may be a
sort of a result of the first four
by gosh effective content marketers
generally have greater percentage
of the overall marketing budget in their
organization
wow okay
that's the b2c marketing program but you
don't understand I I'm not a b2c
marketer okay so let's take a look at
the B2B content marketing formula
guess what
you need to have a documented content
marketing strategy to Be an Effective
B2B content marketer you need to have
someone who oversees content marketing
strategy it helps if you are using more
tactics
and more social media platforms and
guess what you spend a higher percentage
of your overall marketing budget
on content marketing well that's similar
to the b2c content marketers but you
understand B2B is different yeah there's
a couple small differences but guess
what overall the top five criteria
are similar
and when you get the small business
here's what you're going to see
same five criteria
and you're in an Enterprise I know the
world is different for Enterprises
actually not so much
so four different data points let's net
it out there's a pattern
and the pattern is is I don't care what
flavor of content marketer you are you
can be b2c B2B you can be small business
you can be large Enterprise at the end
of the day there are five things that
you've got to focus on
if you want to be effective
we've already covered these and are
there differences between small
businesses and large Enterprises between
B2B and b2c well sure
but they're all at the margin
what's the downside if we don't do this
you know is anyone going to come in and
like wackis and the answer is
um maybe not inside your boardroom
but it may happen on the next sales call
that one of your sales people makes they
may encounter someone I like to call the
man in the chair
and the men in the chair actually refers
back to a classic McGraw-Hill ad
campaign from I think the 1960s
but basically the guy in the chair asks
theoretically some questions from quote
maybe your sales person okay I don't
know anything about you I don't know
about your company I don't know about
your company's product I don't know
about your company's you know reputation
or anything about you and so what was it
you were going to try to sell me
and that's the downside of not having a
Content marketing program
we've actually found and work that we've
done with companies that content
marketing can shorten the sales cycle
why you're providing people with
information at key points that they need
in order to take the next step
so yeah is there a downside sure stick
with the status quo
struggle swimming against the tide you
know what
it's probably smarter to have a Content
marketing program
content marketing strategy
by the end of this lesson you will be
able to outline the steps needed to
create a Content strategy describe the
importance of various parts of a Content
marketing plan including personas brand
story listening and measurements
choose the right channels that will
complement your content
and prioritize and plan content ideas
around your company's biggest
opportunities
content strategy versus content
marketing strategy there is a difference
between content strategy and content
marketing
where content strategy focus on the
actual content content marketing focuses
on the outcome
content strategy is about a management
and creation of the media the tools you
are using the resources you have
available what are the types of content
you will be creating
where content marketing is all about a
customer who are you targeting with the
content how well do you know this person
and most important of all what is the
expected business outcome
are you creating and sharing content to
build brand awareness or are you aiming
to increase Revenue
more generic content marketing questions
are how it fits within your overall
digital marketing strategy what does
your content calendar look like and also
by sharing your content are you exposed
to risk in any way
does your content work for every Market
content creation framework
a good way to start putting together
your content marketing strategy is by
creating your content marketing
framework it enables you to map out the
required content along the customer
buy-in Journey while considering the
impact it has on your online presence
your social media your website and your
sales between these two areas the
customer journey and your overall
digital marketing approach you have the
three types of content you need to focus
on link content conversion content and
Authority content link content is
content that drives traffic from the
internet and from your social media to
your website this is content that is
created with the goal of attracting
quality backlinks for SEO purposes
conversion content is content that
drives web visitors to the next stage in
the buying cycle through call to actions
or ctas this is the content that is is
created with the goal to convince
prospects that they should buy from you
Authority content drives web visitors to
sales through call to actions and drives
repeat traffic to your website this is
content that is created to build a
community of people that trust you and
see you as the expert in your Fields
this is a useful structure to organize
your content and it keeps your focus on
the customer needs and the impact on
your overall digital marketing
objectives
each type of content has different
requirements link content needs to be
high quality and often based on Research
so other websites can refer to it it's
all geared towards generating high
quality backlinks to your website which
Google Sees is very important for your
search ranking make this content fail
proof repurpose it and promote it like
crazy conversion content is based on
helping the customer to go through the
buying cycle this will only work if you
understand what they need and that your
content clearly articulates that you can
help them solve their problem but on top
of that it is vital in this stage that
your content gives them the option to
move to the next stage through very
clear and compelling call to actions and
Authority content is a logical follow-up
from your link content it is content
that confirms you are an expert in your
Fields it helps you to build trust as
long as you are truthful transparent and
show integrity and done continuously and
consistently it helps you to deepen the
relationship with your prospects and
your clients content marketing strategy
there are various steps in developing
your content marketing strategy the
obvious thing of course is to start with
setting your objectives but Additionally
you need to do a number of things create
customer personas create listening
outposts write your Brand Story develop
your channel strategy create your
content marketing Playbook measure your
content marketing and establish your
content marketing Roi let's look at
these elements of your content marketing
strategy in a bit more detail customer
personas
a vital step in your content marketing
strategy is creating customer personas
this is a concept that comes from the
user interface and design World in a
customer Persona you look at things like
demographic characteristics like AIDS
and gender but it is important to add to
this what your pain points are what is
their Affinity with technology where do
they hang out online and what are their
interests and their Hobbies once you
completed your customer personas print
them out and put them on the wall in
your office and make sure you add them
to your breathing document when you ask
your agency to create a new campaign
HubSpot has a great free tool to create
customer personas by asking a set of
questions it will put it in a format for
you that you can share and print and you
can tailor it to your own requirements
and add your own sections it includes
things like education social networks
they use preferred method of
communication tools they need to do
their job goals and objectives
challenges and how they gain knowledge
established listening post an important
part of your content marketing strategy
is to listen to what people are talking
about online you can find out what they
think about your brand the topics they
talk about and if there are any issues
it is also great to listen online to
find good content you could share you
don't have to share just your own
content there's nothing wrong with
sharing relevant content from others
obviously when I say listening online I
mean this in the widest sense watching
videos reading articles or blogs looking
at photos or infographics or literally
listening to podcasts here are a few
tools you can use to listen Feedly is a
reader app on which you can listen to
Live RSS feeds Google Alerts and talk
Walker are tools that will send you a
notification for certain terms that you
have set you can use Google Trends to
find out search transfer keywords your
Brand's story
the next thing you need to work out for
your content marketing strategy is your
Brand Story what is your mission your
vision your values what is the story of
your company your CEO remember people
want to listen and share stories
when I search for IKEA on Google you get
an understanding of what I mean stories
about the history of the company the
founder of the company the way they work
the employees what makes them unique and
the more twists turns and uncertainties
in these stories the more people will
love them
and it gets even better if you can show
them how you overcame obstacles and
bumps in the road this will increase
your credibility
a good example of this is Elon Musk from
Tesla he came from a very simple
background but kept on following his
beliefs even when he was nearly bankrupt
he kept on going and look where he is
now an important element of defining
your content marketing strategy is
understanding of what kind of brand you
are
the type of brand you are determines the
type of social media you will get with
your content
if you are a basic brand you won't get
many people to talk about you let alone
comment on your social media posts
you're just fulfilling a basic need
the only way these Brands can get
engagement on social media is to turn
themselves into a funny brand like
Blendtec blenders who launched the will
it blend campaign if you are a
functional brand you will have customers
who ask questions about how to use your
product you need to respond to that by
offering content in which you answer
their questions
exciting Brands don't have a problem to
get social media engagement with their
content they have thousands of fans who
love to talk about a brand
Harley-Davidson is a classic example
these Brands need to keep on posting
amazing content that become almost like
collector items for their fans
finally vital brands are for the greater
benefit of mankind Greenpeace World
Wildlife Fund UNICEF they have no
problem in getting engagement and
discussions but they should be very
alert on what people are talking about
and try to find influences that can help
them spread their course
so think about it when you start putting
your content marketing strategy together
it will guide you on the type of content
and campaigns you should create and the
types of calls to action you should set
social channel strategy before you're
going to decide on the type of content
you're going to create it makes sense to
agree on the social media channels you
are going to use in the listening stage
you have learned on which channels your
clients hang out so now you're going to
make sure you are there as well you're
going to synchronize The Branding the
key messages and the campaigns to grow
your followers on these channels you
need to make sure you understand the
latest features and Trends on these
social channels it is also good to do a
Content Gap analysis what type of
content do you already have for each
Channel and where are the gaps so you
know what type of content you need to
create here is a usual template you can
use for this it shows you the channels
the structure the tone of voice for each
Channel and the desired action the gaps
will give you an indication of the work
you need to do to make sure you have a
coherent content marketing strategy
content marketing Playbook
so now you are in a position to decide
on the type of content you're going to
create here is a list structured by the
three types of content we saw earlier
link conversion and Authority content
link content and Authority content can
be fairly similar it's more on the
promotion site where they differ but the
conversion content needs to be organized
along the customer Journey from
awareness to evaluation to purchase we
call this the marketing Playbook you
need to create your own by selecting the
right content for the right stage
measuring content marketing efforts you
can measure the traffic you get through
your content you can measure the
engagement you get and you can measure
the sentiments whether you are targeting
consumers or businesses the metrics are
the same but the priorities May differ
today lead generation is seen as the
number one kpi when it comes to
measuring the success of your content
marketing closely followed by traffic
generation to your website these metrics
show how your content marketing efforts
are succeeding but you need to go a
level deeper to discover what specific
content campaigns channels and efforts
are most effective in driving value and
in the end whether you are in b2c or B2B
it comes down to measuring the ROI of
your content marketing how much money
did you earn from your content Marketing
in relation to the cost you incurred in
creating and distributing it
the things that can improve your Roi are
quality of your leads sales web traffic
engagement SEO success and brand
exposure and remember improved Roi is
not just based on more sales it can also
be based on lowering costs planning your
content marketing strategy planning your
content marketing strategy is very
important there are so many things you
need to take into consideration if you
don't put some structure into this you
may lose control it is best to create
your content marketing process guide in
this guide you specify how you create
and manage your content how you optimize
and curate how you listen and engage in
conversations and how you measure your
content marketing besides this there is
the Tactical stuff like roles and
responsibilities what are the style and
writing guidelines and similar what are
the guidelines for posting and
Publishing and make sure you communicate
a process guide to the relevant people
in your organization you may want to put
a training together to the people who
will work with this on a daily basis a
vital part of your process guide is the
content marketing calendar it's the
calendar that contains your content
production and publication schedule
there are many templates and tools for
this on the internet my favorite ones
are trello.com and Google Calendar the
most important part of it is that it is
a collaborative tool so you can schedule
the calendar with your colleagues or
with your clients you can give people
viewing or editing access you can use
color codes for the different types of
content or for the different channels
becoming a Content marketing company
to give you a framework on how to
organize your content marketing strategy
in your company you can look at the
content marketing Institute for business
models for Content marketing
they can be mapped in a quadrant with
strategic importance on one access and
internal external focus on the other
you're a player when your content
marketing strategy is focused on
supporting teams within the organization
like your product marketing or marketing
communication teams
most companies started content marketing
like this it's seen as a contributor
you're a performer when your content
marketing is seen as a center of
excellence in your organization it has
an external Focus where audience
segmentation is key it can be seen as a
support function to other parts in the
organization you're a processor when you
centralize certain content functions but
not the actual creation of it
your corporate team may create a Content
campaigns with the corporate guidelines
where your local teams are responsible
for local content creation to execute a
campaign
and you're a platform when you approach
your content marketing as a strategic
business within your business
often this is done on a corporate level
and this is separate from local content
marketing initiatives
so you need to understand where you are
today and have a vision of where you
want to go
so here are the key takeaways from this
lesson
content strategy is the management of
any tangible media written visual or
audible that you create and own content
marketing is about creating and
distributing valuable relevant and
consistent content to generate website
traffic and new leads the content
creation framework consists of linked
content conversion content and Authority
content it puts your content in the
context of the customer Journey a
customer Persona is a semi-fictional
representation of your ideal customer
based on market research and real data
about your existing customers
stories are the currency of content
marketing and your story starts with
your mission and your editorial
statements and content marketing Roi is
how much revenue you gain from your
content Marketing in comparison to what
you spent on creating and distributing
your in today's video we are going to be
talking about content writing now we'll
talk about why it is important how do
you write good content what are the
different types of content that you can
write for and for the different types of
media that you want to use and I'm going
to share with you some really good
content writing tools I am our campman
I'm your digital navigator for this
video but before we start if you like
this video click the like button and if
you want to join our subscribers click
the Subscribe button and click on the
notifications Button as well so you will
get automatic notifications when we come
up with new query new videos so you're
ready let's get started let me give you
some interesting statistics about
content and about content marketing of
which content writing is an important
part did you know that the content
marketing industry is worth more than
400 billion dollars which is going to
grow to close to 900 billion dollars in
the next five years
46 percent of businesses plan to
increase their spent in content creation
content marketing costs 62 percent less
than traditional outbound marketing
methods and it generates three times
more leads
so quite impressive numbers yeah among
buyers of B2B products and services more
than 90 percent consider content to be
worthwhile when they evaluate any
business
so we spent on average seven hours per
day consuming digital content and a lot
of this content is being consumed on
blogs did you know that there are over
500 million blogs on the internet and on
WordPress about 70 million blog posts
are published each month so these are
incredible numbers and we're going to be
talking about that yeah in this section
in this module we're going to be talking
about a very important part of content
marketing which is the actual creation
of content particularly when it comes to
writing right so let's get started what
are we going to be talking about in this
video we are going to be talking about
many things in the content marketing
industry did you know that content
writing is one of the fastest changing
areas of content marketing now you may
wonder what let me give you the answer
to this that is mainly because of
developments in artificial intelligence
if you use AI or artificial intelligence
tools you actually no longer have to
write the content you let those tools
write a content for you and the only
thing you will have to do is to edit the
end
um the output of the AI tool later I'm
going to share some AI tools with you
that you can be using for Content
writing but to understand these new
tools it is important that you
understand the basics of content writing
so in this video we will look at what is
content writing
why proper content writing is important
we'll look at the different types of
content that you can write for we'll
look at how to write proper content and
that is a skill in itself and I'm going
to close with right giving you some
content writing tips and in the process
of going through these uh topics I will
be sharing with you some interesting
content writing tools as well so let's
start at the beginning what is content
writing many people when they think
about content writing they think about
writing an article however writing
content isn't just in for a Blog yeah it
is for many many topics many other areas
that you can write for you can write for
many different areas you can write a
script for your video you can write for
your email newsletter you can write for
the pages of your website you maybe have
to write a keynote speech maybe for your
social media post posts you have to
write titles for your podcast for your
videos maybe you're going to produce a
white paper that you need to write for
or an ebook landing pages are very
important content that you have to write
for it could be the descriptions for
your videos remember we talked about
YouTube SEO and we talked about how
important description of your video is
and writing for SEO purposes we talked
about that in other videos as well but
it's in another way writing is the
foundation for pretty much any content
that you publish
so what then is content writing content
writing as we say on the slide is the
process of planning writing and editing
web content typically for digital
marketing purposes
so it can include writing a blog post
and articles a script for your videos it
could be writing the show notes for your
podcast and it can also be content for
specific social media platforms the
thing they have in common you have to
write it before you can publish this and
that is where the challenges in content
writing you need to know how to write
and many people they don't think they
know how to write
well for those people who are afraid of
writing content rest issued after this
video you will be a lot less anxious to
get your pen or keyboard and put your
creative ideas on paper or on the screen
yes so that is what the basic essence of
content writing is now remember content
writing is not just for a blog post as I
mentioned earlier content writing
touches every aspect of your digital
marketing without good written content
your digital marketing strategy will
fail because it's the content that will
connect your readers with you and that
content that features everywhere in your
digital marketing and I can't emphasize
this enough I mentioned that before it
is on your blog post it's on your video
script it's in your email newsletters
it's in your podcast title it's in your
landing pages in your YouTube video
descriptions there's so many places
where your content and will feature and
you can replicate a Content across those
different platforms so written once for
one medium doesn't mean you can't use it
on other medium so won't this look
golden of content marketing the goal of
good writing of content writing is to
connect your readers with your business
and in such a way that you communicate
your message effectively and efficiently
and the better you're able to do this
the more likely the reader will engage
with you
so it's that engagement that turns into
trust and into loyalty so let me give
you an example you know the Michelin
tires in the early 1900s the Michelin
Brothers they started supplying
pneumatic tires to automobiles in France
now automobiles were mainly used in
Paris and of course the Michelin
Brothers they wanted to sell their tires
to more automobile users to more car
users across the country
cars were in that popular yet but they
wanted to give it a push so people would
take their cars to the countryside so
Michelin knew that to grow their
business to had to get they had to get
people to drive their cars outside Paris
and that's when the Michelin guide was
born yeah a book that contained the
rating systems for restaurants all over
France and also included information
about roads across France where to find
gas stations about hotels and of course
information about how to replace flat
tires or how to repair them and other
important facts about using a car so
this early example of content marketing
became a huge success and they were able
to build a global brand based on the
Michelin guide and the Michelin guide is
still being used today so having talked
about this what is content marketing why
then is it so important let's have a
talk about that yeah the essence of
content marketing as I said earlier is
to guide the customer or your prospects
through their buying money yeah and
content writing is key to this remember
your content that you should give to
people or share with people when they
don't even know that they want to where
they want to go on a vacation for
instance is different than when they
have already made up their mind of going
on a beach vacation in uh in Barcelona
yeah if I don't know what vacation I
want I want to find content about what
our holiday Beach holidays what are city
breaks what are Adventure holidays yeah
if I know what I want to do where I want
to go then I want to know informative
content I want to see content about
Barcelona about hotels in Barcelona
about what you can do during Beach
vacations yeah so it's very important
that your content drives your customer
or your prospect through that buying
Journey so you write content for
awareness purposes great content that
will go viral and reach as many people
as possible by creating well-informed
well-written well entertained and useful
content it will drive traffic to your
website and you will appear higher in
search engine rankings
next your content has to convey
information
yeah where you capture those in a
Content those people that have seen your
content you want to make sure that they
want to see more of your content yes so
you need to give them information that
will persuade them to take a certain
action I want to download an ebook or I
want to know more information about
something or want to sign up for a
newsletter or sign up for a webinar or
simply buy your product or service in
doing that you use your content to turn
awareness into interest which will lead
to more sales and will lead to referrals
it's a very simple and effective process
in marketing terms we call this inbound
marketing where you're going to reach as
many people as possible online who will
then if they're interested come back to
you and engage with you
as opposed to outbound marketing where
you will go and get a list of telephone
numbers and your salesperson will call
everybody one at a time with a script
now that script needs to be written as
well in fact that is also content
writing yeah but inbound marketing is a
much more cost efficient way of
generating leads for this for businesses
these days so to summarize instead of
reaching out to individual prospects you
publish really good content that drives
traffic to your website which will lead
to more leads and ultimately will lead
to more sales so let's talk about the
types of content and the types of
content formats now when people think
about digital content they mostly think
about content for your website which is
the text they see on the web pages now
that's very important but there's a lot
more to that let me show you an
infographic that puts content writing
into a perspective
yep so that is different types of
content so here it will share the link
to this in the um in the description but
here you see the different types of
content that can be written for you can
have technical writing you have press
release white writing report writing and
research writing SEO content writing
marketing and communication writing
instructional design writing
CSR writing for social courses
editorial and publication writing
feature writing ghost writing is a form
of content writing as well where you
write for somebody else business writing
copywriting that is an interesting form
of writing yeah where you look at a
really competitive
creativity that you need to create get
to have very strong headlines for
instance so a lot of different types of
content that you can be writing for so
let's focus on the different types that
we can use particularly for marketing
yeah let me go back to the slides
yes so here is a summary of the
different types when it comes to
e-marketing we're looking at articles
yeah these are pieces that can be
published in a newspaper in a magazine
or in an online publication yep and that
is a very common type of content that
can be written for and that you will use
for your marketing purposes they can be
the traditional content like brochure or
product descriptions yes so a brochure
is like an advertising piece that
included template a booklet or a leaflet
and they have information about your
products about your services of course
as you differentiate Us and how people
can reach out to you
so that is an important part of content
as well then a very important part of
content is content for your website
yeah the pages on your website the
content in your website needs to be
written each page needs to be written
yeah they need to be written what you
see but also kind of needs to be written
what you don't see but what the search
engine
um
spiders will see and that's of course
when we talk about search engine
optimization very important you write
content for emails like email
newsletters
yeah or it could be just email campaigns
very important parts you have your
headers or your titles of your emails
you have the description the summary of
your emails
press releases has been a long sort of
the type a very important part of
content that we've been written for many
many years yeah where in the early
pre-internet days press releases were
one of the most important documents to
reach out to journalists now press
releases are just another type of
content that you can share with your
your audience
and then finally ebooks is a very
important type of content ebooks were
also we call those lead magnets yeah
they are fantastic for adding to your
website where people when they're
interested can download them so that's
where the magnet comes in people are
interested they click on download to
ebook but before they download they have
to give them they have to enter their
email address and or their telephone
number so very important different types
of content that you can be focusing on
so here is the big question
can everybody write good content
yeah so a lot of people think oh no I'm
not good in writing so I need to get a
copywriter in now before I can answer
the question if everybody is good in
proper in content writing let's discuss
the difference between copywriting and
content writing often they will overlap
yeah and many writers they act as both a
copywriter and a Content writer but then
what there is a difference it's a very
subtle difference
copywriters usually focus on persuading
readers in selling a brand
it's often short form it appears on ads
on products on taglines and similar
types of marketing copy so it's short
it's punchy it's capturing the essence
in a couple of statements that's often
what we call copywriting content writing
is usually for longer form content
focusing on informing educating or
entertaining the readers it's content as
we said earlier that takes the reader
through their buying Journey so while
it's true that anyone can write it's not
enough to just put the words on a page
content writers and copywriters must
craft something compelling something
original something engaging and
ultimately something well written
and when you're able to do that of
course the quality we're able to do that
producing high quality content the
benefits are huge yeah it gives you
something to use across all your
marketing channels yeah so you can turn
a blog post into an Instagram post into
a Facebook post into a tweet into a blog
post on LinkedIn yeah so lots of
different things that you can do with a
good piece of content
good content really helps you with
search engine optimization
Google will reward you for having new
fresh content on your website by giving
you a higher search ranking good content
helps you establish your Authority in
your end your in your Niche or in your
industry thereby it helps you in
establishing your brand and also good
content will go viral it will go wide it
will reach many people and that means it
will reach potentially new customers
so very important to think about these
benefits that you will get from good
proper content writing
and as I said everybody can write
content but your challenge is to make
sure your copy your copy that you write
is compelling original engaging and
ultimately well written but as I
mentioned earlier there are many tools
now and particularly in the artificial
intelligence field that can help you in
to turn boring content into very
exciting content so let me give you some
tips on how to write exciting content or
as I like to call it killer content
the first thing you need to do is to
Define your target audience
yeah who are you writing for
do you understand their needs do you
understand their interests do you
understand their pains
yeah a an e-book for a marketing
director will be different than an ebook
for a finance director so you need to
know who you're writing for
in digital marketing terms we talk about
customer personas
yeah you need to Define to create your
customer personas and here is a tool
that I like to share with you it is a
tool from HubSpot make my personas in
HubSpot it talks about what is a Persona
what is a buyer Persona you can learn
about it but here you also see build my
Persona yes so if you click on that it
takes you through a simple process in a
walk through mode where you can create
your own customer personas
you can also skip the walkthrough mode
and then here you see a typical Persona
the name job title age their level of
Education what social networks are they
using what is their preferred method of
communication what are their
responsibilities what are their goals
and objectives what are their pain
points their challenges you do this for
your most important customers so if
you're selling to marketing directors
this could be marketing Jill yeah or
Finance directors it could be Finance
Joe or Finance Mark or if you're talking
to women with children who buy shoes
yeah then it could be
um
Family Jane yeah so very important to
create customer personas once you've
created those customer personas you're
going to look at your next step it's
where you're going to choose a topic
when you choose a topic you find a topic
that you're going to write about that is
relevant for your audience and it aligns
with your business and your organization
goals a really good tool that you can
use here to write proper content is a
tool called Google trend
Google Trends yeah it helps you explore
what the world is searching for so let's
say I'm going to write an article about
remote working yeah then here I see the
trends I want the trends worldwide
and here I can see give me the trends
for the past let's say 2004 till present
and here I can see the trends in the
term remote working from 2004 to
2023. now these are the volumes of
people searching for the term remote
working and interesting that you can see
here as well how it develops and here
you see tape for instance this Spike
where did this Spike come from guess
what this was the start of covet yeah so
there was a surge in people that had to
start working remotely and you see that
it gives findings you see that in the
results on Google Trends as well if this
trend would go down yeah so take for
instance a term like
a video recorder yep and we're going
back to Global worldwide and we're going
to do from 2004 till present yeah so you
see clearly very popular in the 2010
tens but you don't want to write about
video recorders today because it is a
dead topic
okay so that is the power of Google
search a very good tool to check the
topics that you want to write for are
they gaining are they popular are they
gaining in popularity or are they going
down in popularity once you've decided
on your topic you're going to do the
next thing and you're going to research
the topic yeah so you're going to gather
information about your topic from
reliable sources
yeah you're gonna check if there is
other people writing about the topic can
you learn from that can you get some
ideas from that so you can form your own
opinion before you start writing the
content a really good tool that you can
use for this
is a tool called bus shumo
in bus Sumo you can just analyze content
that has been published on the internet
yes so let's look at working or remote
working yeah when I'm gonna search for
that then bus Sumo is going to give me
an analysis of the most popular articles
on the internet at this moment about the
topic remote working here you see how
much engagement the topic gets how many
shares on Facebook how much engagement
on Reddit number of links and here you
see the total engagement of that article
yes so very good to research articles
because if this is a very popular
article then you may want to read the
article and get ideas from that article
okay so that is how you analyze content
the next thing you're going to do once
you've analyzed the content you are and
conducted to research you're going to
create an outline
yeah so you're going to come up with
ideas you're going to look at the
structure of your content you're going
to look at the topics of your content
you're going to get some ideas about
titles for your content once you have
that outline like say five or six
bullets it helps you to stay focused and
make sure that your content flows
logically now when this is where
artificial intelligence comes in yeah
this is where you can use tools to help
you in creating that outline a really
good and easy tool to use here is a tool
called simplified.com
yeah in simplified.com it helps you to
write for AI purposes if I go home you
can see you can write content you can
write a YouTube script you can expand
sentences you can make them shorter and
there's a lot more that you can do you
can actually there's a full blog wizard
you can write a full blog post for you
yeah but you can also just create a new
document let me show you I'm not going
to demo the whole product but here you
can see the flow that you will go
through so the first thing you want
block titles and ideas
yeah and there are templates that I can
pick for this yeah the topic is going to
be let's say a remote working
yep and now I'm going to just click
generate and the tool is now going to
generate block titles for me yeah so
seven ways to make remote working a
success for you and your company the top
10 benefits of working remotely eight
steps for a successful remote working
setup the benefits of working remotely
Etc so let's take for instance
um
so the top 10 benefits of working
remotely what I'm going to do I'm going
to add this to my article there we have
it number one yeah and if you look at
the topics here it can also create your
blog introduction the section completer
a conclusion prayer paragraph it can
even put it into the
um the customer buying Journey framework
so it is unbelievable what these type of
AIS AI tools can do for you another very
powerful a very simple product that I
often use is a tool called quill Bots
if I go to quill bot it's a paraphrasing
tool yeah and this is free you can use
standard and fluency for free you just
type in or paste the piece of text that
you want to rewrite and then you click
paraphrase yeah you can increase the
number of synonyms you can make it
fluent formal simple creative expand and
shorten the text a very simple but
powerful tool to paraphrase content so
watch this space yeah the artificial
intelligence is taking the digital
marketing World by storm okay
once you've got your outline written
you're then going to write a very
compelling headline writing the
compelling headline is probably one of
the most important parts of your
copywriting that people will remember
he has showing that that headline must
summarize what the content is all about
but also it should grabs people's
attention now there are many tools that
you can use to check your title yeah and
just search for tool to check title yeah
and then you will come up with a whole
selection of tools that you can use for
this also think about the paragraphs and
the bullet points it's very important to
break your content into short paragraphs
and to use bullet points to make it
easier for people to read and to scan
your article there's another reason why
short paragraphs and bullet points are
so important Google likes them and
particularly when it comes to
um to mobile search where Google needs
to place short content as answers to
queries that people have they prefer to
have bullets at content to actually use
for answering queries that people have
so finally there are a few more tips we
have subheadings subheadings are very
important and formatting is important
yeah headings are the first level of
your writing Masterpiece yeah so
headings is sort of the title of your
document they introduced a topic they
introduced a paragraph So The Heading
let the reader know where they are in
the document or the blog post they can
also include keywords yeah that relate
to the topic and again that's good for
your search optimization The Heading is
an essential part of the content that
you're writing because it tells the
reader what to expect from that piece of
text
subheadings are the second level of a
document they introduce a topic or a
paragraph
their function is to break up longer
sections into smaller more manageable
pieces
sin gave it as a bullet point under your
heading so headings and subheadings are
the signposts of your content they
indicate the summary of a section
written under a heading or subheading so
it helps people to quickly understand
the section that is following and then
of course the formatting is important to
let pieces of content come out as well
like bold italics underlining using
different colors that can make your
content more visually appealing
right so now that we looked at how you
can write proper content yeah the mod
the final piece is of course to edit and
proofread and proofread and edit yes so
constant editing is very important you
may want to have multiple people
contributing to your document yeah so
very useful to ask your colleagues to
have a look at a document and maybe add
their comments add their ideas to the um
the content as well and then when your
final piece is ready make sure that
before you publish it you proofread it
for spelling and grammar errors
yeah and that's where word processors
these days of course they all have
spelling Checkers so that's the minimum
you should do is to have a spelling
checker go through your document now
typos are very easy to miss when you
check it on your screen
so my advice is to print your document
yep and then read it on paper that will
give you a different view of your
document and you will see that you often
take out typos if it is a shorter
document a very powerful way to
proofread is to read it backwards yeah
because when you're reading it backwards
you're not thinking ahead of what the
sentence actually will be but you're
just analyzing each word by itself
good so that is all about writing proper
content let me close today's session
with some particular content writing
tips
first of all know your purpose we talked
about that make sure that you know what
you're writing you know who you're
writing it for do you want your content
to inform do you want it to convince do
you want it to entertain yeah so what is
your content going to be about and who
is it going to be for so know your
purpose
I always use a very simple acronym kiss
keep it simple
sometimes I keep I use kiss with two s's
keep it simple and stupid use Clear
concise language and avoid jargon or
technical terms that may be confusing to
your audience ask your mom to read it
because if she doesn't understand it
then maybe some of your customers may
not understand it it's very simple to
very important to keep it simple and
since you're so involved in your product
and services for you the technical terms
are day-to-day language for your readers
they are probably not day-to-day
language
use active voice yes so writing active
voice makes your content more engaging
yeah so it is you're not talking about
that day the people of our company
decided but you say that they we decided
yes so use terms like we like us in your
documents so use the active voice that
makes it much easier to engage with
use images and media of course text is
the core element of your content writing
but you can spice up your document with
images and media
or videos and other forms of media make
it visually appealing
people read but people will remember
what they see and people will remember
what they hear so yes your content
writing is important but spices up with
good
good images and other forms of media
yeah now when you use images or photos
make sure that you're using royalty free
videos or photos or that you pay
royalties on the photos that you want to
use
there's no better photo images to use
than your own images yeah so use your
own photos do a photo shoot for your
products and create your own library or
photos if you want to use royalty free
photos one of my favorite tools for that
is a tool called karate socrophy in
karate discography there's truly unique
usually Whimsy photos photos so they are
slightly different than the photos you
would get from the traditional photo
libraries
yep so be aware make sure that you use
quotas photos of the best content in
your in your content that you're that
you're creating
use formatting to your advantage we
talked about formatting use headings
bullet points bowling color can make it
a lot easier to read so use that to your
advantage and then use the storytelling
technique now storytelling is a term
that has come into marketing about a
number of years ago particularly when
everybody started talking about content
marketing people are naturally drawn to
stories
yeah and there are lots of techniques
that you can use to create stories to
make your content more engaging and more
memorable
so storytelling is a concept that is now
adopted by most brands that are online
because again people will remember good
stories so let me give you my five C's
of Storytelling the first C is the Sea
of circumstance so when you create your
content write the circumstance write the
environment write the situation that
you're trying to describe to portray
the next C is to see for curiosity
people are curious so address this
curiosity feeling put questions make
people curious about the answers that
you're going to give them
yeah so curiosity is a very important
part of your storytelling the next C is
the Sea of characters people identify
with characters if you create a
character in your story use a character
whether it's a hero whether it's a
villain yeah then people will identify
with those characters and they often
remember those characters
those characters have conversations and
that is the fifth the fourth C of the
storytelling people have conversations
so let your characters tell stories of
conversations with other people
and then the final C is the Sea of
conflict and to me that is one of the
most powerful aspects of Storytelling it
is conflict every good story has a
conflict
good movies have a hero and have a
villain good movies have adversity and
have
good luck or have a um a world without
the adversity yes so it's conflict it is
um two sides of the of the coin yeah
it's positive it's negative it's here
it's there so create that conflict in
your story one of the companies that
uses con
storytelling at its best is a company
called
Airbnb you may have booked
through Airbnb but Airbnb is fantastic
in storytelling so here is a section of
their website it's called Airbnb
experiences
Unforgettable activities hosted by
locals so this is where local people who
are having their Airbnb on the who are
having their house or their Chalet or
their condo on Airbnb where they share
their stories of things to do in the
environment that they where they will
rent the house
so very powerful in content marketing
and in storytelling so have a look at
this it is really good
okay so that is the telling your story
as a very important part of your content
marketing so the next thing you want to
focus in on is making sure that your
content has very strong goals to action
when people read your content make sure
that they have somewhere where they can
click to go to the next step
yeah that could be registering for a
newsletter
signing up for a webinar
or getting more information or
downloading an ebook
calls to action are vital in digital
marketing because in the end you want
your reader to become a customer
and then it goes without saying make
sure that you have a consistent tone and
style throughout your content so we call
this a house style so many Brands before
they start creating content they have a
document which summarizes their house
style their tone of voice their visual
identity the colors that they're using
the fonts they're using how you can use
the logo
Etc it's all about creating a cohesive
and professional image
and then there's two more tips that I
want to share with you before we wrap up
make sure that you keep your content up
to date yeah there's various reasons why
you want to do that to make sure that
your customers when they read your
content read the latest and the greatest
second it helps you to put new life in
your document if new things have
happened in your industry add it to your
document and republish it again so it
means it means that your document
remains relevant is accurate and Google
likes that as well and then finally
as part of your storytelling use
examples and use anecdotes use real life
examples to help illustrating your
points to make your content more
relatable and more engaging and that is
where storytelling comes in that's where
your conversations come in that's where
your characters come in and often
customers are very good characters to
talk about your products and can give
you examples in the content that you are
writing now let me tell you about simply
lens postgraduate program in digital
marketing created in collaboration with
Purdue University and meta blueprint
with this program you will learn
everything from the fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and more this program is
led by industry experts who bring their
real world experience to the classroom
giving you an Insider's perspective on
what it takes to succeed in the digital
marketing world if you're looking to
jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply lens professional
certificate program in digital marketing
is the perfect place to start to learn
more about the course you can click the
link in the description box below
welcome to the simply learned YouTube
channel in today's video we are going to
be talking about a Google Keyword
Planner a tool that will help you
putting together your Google ads
campaign or it can also help you in
deciding for your keywords for your
search engine optimization we will talk
about what is Google Keyword Planner how
do you use it and how what are the
benefits of it and how can you sort of
bypass some of its shortcomings
imrcampland I'm your digital navigator
for this video and before we start if
you like the video click the like button
and of course if you want to subscribe
to our YouTube channel then click Below
on the Subscribe button right so let
these start by giving you some
interesting stats about Google
advertising Google is the Undisputed
market leader when it comes to digital
advertising their market share is over
80 percent followed by Bing Yahoo and
Yandex now 63 of people who are online
they do click on Google ads and you may
hear that people always say I never
click on ads but people actually do and
a lot of those ads are actually on
mobile
33 of mobile ad spending goes actually
to Google
so Google's ad Revenue in the third
quarter in 2022 was 54 billion US
dollars yeah that is an annual revenue
of over 200 billion dollars which is a
staggering amount
the beauty about advertising on mobile
or in on the on desktop is that it gives
you an immediate sort of payback yeah
therefore the Gen PPC generates twice as
many visitors than for instance search
engine optimization does but PPC cost
money compared to SEO does not cost
money other than your own time and
resources
so Google advertising is there it's
there to stay and it is one of the major
channels that you should be using for
reaching out to your audiences
so let's then have a look at one of the
most important tools that Google makes
available to help you with putting
together your advertising campaigns
which is the Google Keyword Planner yep
so and by the way if you want to know
Google Keyword Planner is a free tool
yep so you don't have to buy it it is
embedded in the Google ads tool that
Google has and it will I will show you
later in the demo how to access it and
how to use it
so here are the topics that we will be
talking about in this video we're going
to be talking about what is Google
planner we'll look at imported terms
related to Google Keyword Planner we'll
look at some of the features of Google
Keyword Planner and then I will be
giving you a demo of how to use Google
Keyword Planner
um what are the best parts of Google
Keyword Planner and how can you bypass
some of its shortcomings and then I will
close the presentation with some tips
and tricks on Google Keyword Planner
so before we go into Google Keyword
Planner let's talk about keywords yeah
keywords we use them everywhere and they
save as the foundation of nearly every
marketing campaign that we launch online
whether you're deploying Google ads
cleaning up content for SEO helping your
products to be found on Amazon
keywords are at the heart of how you
connect with your customers or your
ideal prospects so they are used for
pay-per-click and for SEO purposes
in the context of an SEO campaign a
keyword is a phrase a query that a
Searcher types into the browser to prove
to get a list of results examples of SEO
keywords could include words like
accounting software QuickBooks for
self-employed workers or online
bookkeeping Solutions
now PPC keywords are used for your
advertising like Google ads your ad you
add a keywords to your Google ads setup
to help determine when and where your
ads should appear
yep so somebody types in a query Google
matches that query with ads that contain
that query yep and then with various
calculations it will show the ads that
best answers the query so a great
keyword list can help improve the
performance of your ads and help you to
avoid a high price to pay for your ads
poor keywords can ultimately cause you
to have higher price to pay for your ads
and lower ad positions
so at the beginning of any SEO or PPC
campaign you should plan to invest time
to do your keyword research much of this
process can be automated and Google
Keyword Planner is a fantastic tool that
can help you with that but remember in
the end it's still humans who need to
look over the list to properly determine
the keyword relevance
so let's have a look at some of the
features of Google Keyword Planner and
what Google Keyword Planner actually is
so Google Keyword Planner is a tool that
helps advertisers find the right
keywords to Target for their Google ad
campaigns
yeah it helps you research the keywords
for your search campaigns and you can
also discover new keywords related to
your business you could identify your
competitors keywords and get ideas
around the keywords that your
competitors are using additionally
Google Keyword Planner will give you
volumes estimates of the searches that
those keywords receive and the cost you
would potentially pay when you use those
keywords in your advertising campaign
yeah so Google Keyword Planner allows
you to see how often certain keywords
are searched for on Google and it
provides data of the cost of running the
ads for those keywords so you get also
suggestions for related keywords it's
great if you don't really know where to
start as far as finding keywords for
your ad so very important to know that
Google also provides the average cost
for your ads to show on searches for a
keyword so it's easier to pick and chose
choose which keywords best suit your
strategy and your budget
so Google keywords planner is a useful
tool for identifying the most effective
keywords to use in your ad campaign and
as I said before as well for estimating
the potential cost and reach of a
campaign
so knowing how frequently keywords in
your industry are searched for is
extremely important for your campaign
because you wouldn't want to Target
keywords that no one is using but you
also want to Target keywords that have a
ridiculously high search volume because
they tend to be more competitive and
when they are more competitive you will
have to pay a higher price to Target
those keywords so to summarize Google
Keyword Planner helps you discover new
Search keywords
it shows you average monthly search
numbers for those keywords it helps you
to determine the cost and it helps you
to create new search ad campaigns so all
in all a very powerful tool that you can
use for your Google ad campaigns which
is also completely integrated with
Google ads so the keyword list that you
create in Google Keyword Planner you can
then bring directly into your Google ads
campaign setup
so here are some important terms related
to Google Keyword Planner
so there is keywords of course keywords
now what is a keyword a keyword is a
word or a phrase that users type into a
search engine to find information on a
particular topic from an end user
perspective you could say it's a query
yeah and advertisers use those keywords
to Target their ads to users who are
searching for specific products or
services or have questions around
problems that they have now search
volume is the number of times a
particular keyword is search for on
Google over a certain period of time so
Keyword Planner provides you data on
search volume to help you understand how
popular certain keywords are match type
refers to the way in which a keyword
will trigger an ad Google offers several
different match types like broad match
phrase match and exact match it goes
from exact match where Google will
actually only look at the exact word or
phrase that you specified as a keyword
compared to Broad match where it will
look at a much broader sort of range of
keywords in relation to the search term
that you defined in your Google ads
setup
an ad group is the container for your
keywords yeah it's a set of keywords
that are related to a specific theme or
topic so ad groups are used to organize
and structure your ad campaign and each
ad group can have its own sets of ads
and targeting options in relation to the
keywords that you specified keywords can
be negative as we say yeah so negative
keywords is a word or phrase that Google
will not show an ad for in when it comes
to certain search queries yes so it have
helped you to avoid wasting Impressions
on irrelevant searches and thereby it
improves the relevance of your ads
so if your keyword is accounting because
you're selling accounting software you
don't want people who search for
accounting jobs yet to see your ad
because they will not be interested in
buying your accounting software so you
can specify jobs as a negative keyword
as I said earlier Google Keyword Planner
will also give you traffic estimate
traffic estimates are estimates of the
potential reach and cost of an ad
campaign based on the selected keywords
and Keyword Planner provides those
traffic estimates to help you with your
budget setting and targeting options for
your campaigns there are important
metrics as well that are related to
Google Keyword Planner and therefore of
course also related to Google ads a cost
per click is the amount that you will
pay each time a user clicks on your ads
yeah that's why we call Google ads
pay-per-click advertising you're not
paying paying Yeah by default you're not
paying on when people see your ads you
will pay when people click on your ads
and of course what you want to know for
your campaign what is the average cost
per click
you also want to know what the
click-through rate for your campaign is
there is a ratio of the number of times
an ad was clicked in comparison to the
number of times it was shown and that
expressed as a percentage so two
important indicators cost per click and
click-through rate
finally there is a very important term
is what we call long tail keywords
yeah they are more specific keyword
phrases that visitors are more likely to
use when they're closer to a point of
purchase
yeah so a normal keyword can be dog food
yeah and you see it has a very high
search volume which means the higher the
search volume the more likely you will
pay a higher cost per click because the
competition is very high for those
keywords
yes so what brands do what what do
companies do is actually they step away
from the intense competition on the
long-term keyword or the the short-term
keywords like dog food and they move to
longer term keywords like how to make
dog food at home
it gives you a lower search volume but
the chance that people will engage with
you on your ads is bigger because they
are closer to that point of purchase
okay so those are long tail keywords
right so let's have a look at some of
the Keyword Planner features
so to summarize yeah Google Keyword
Planner gives you search volume data for
keywords once you put a keyword in you
get that volume data but it will also
give you ideas for keyword yep and it
will actually automatically group those
ideas for you in potential ad groups
that you can use it will then give you
traffic estimates and you can say use
filters as well to make your keyword
list more specific right
so let's have a look at how Google
Keyword Planner works yeah and it's
important to understand that before you
can use Google Keyword Planner you will
need to have a Google ad account weapon
unique can create that by going to
Google ad you will have to put in your
credit card or debit cards yeah but as
long as you're not publishing any
campaigns you won't get charged by
Google so there there's no risk for you
to when you enter your credit card
details okay and then when you're in and
I'll show you in a minute where you can
find it then you just start entering
your keywords and then Google Keyword
Planner will do the rest for you
so let's have a look at how Google
Keyword Planner works first of all we
need to go to Google ads so let's type
in Google ads and I assume yeah or the
fact is you will need a um a Google ads
account to be able to access Google
Keyword Planner so when I sign into my
Google ads account I click here on the
account that I want to use for this demo
and this takes me to the Google ads
interface
so this is of course a different topic
to talk about Google ads which we will
do in other videos for now it is
important to find out where do I find
Google a Keyword Planner and how do I
access it so when you click here in the
top on tools and settings
you will hear see all the tools that you
have available for planning for your
shared library for bulk actions for
measurements setting up your Google ads
billing for your Google ads but here
under the planning you see Keyword
Planner and that takes you straight to
the Google Keyword Planner so here is
the interface so here you see
plans that you've created for keywords
yes so you can save your keywords into
ad groups you can save those ad groups
into plans
and what you can then do is import those
plans as it were in your Google ads
campaign but what we're particularly
interested in for now is how do I
discover new keywords and how do I get
search volumes and forecasts those are
the two areas where you can get data
about your keywords so let's start with
looking at Discover the keywords so here
you go and there's two ways to find
keywords you can start with keywords you
can also start with a website so what
you do here you put in the keywords that
you want to look for so I can here put
for instance SEO
I can put in link building
and I can put in a keyword research
and click on that
yep so I can unfiltered unrelated
keywords I can put that in and entering
a site so I can make it as specific as
possible but let's go for these three
keywords
get the results
yeah and here you see my three keywords
and here you see a whole range of
keyword ideas
yeah and that is very of course Very
powerful very useful information these
are all words in relation to my three
words that I specified SEO link building
and keyword research
now what is the data it will give you
the average monthly searches you see
that here in bands from 10K to 100k from
1K to 10K it will give you the
competition level for the keywords now
bear in mind this is competition level
for Google pay-per-click advertising it
is not a competition level for the
actual keyword so
um yep and then here you see the top of
page bit the low range and here you see
the top of bit high range
yes so that is kind of the interface
here you have your keyword view you can
specify your columns you can exclude
ideas in this case add all suggestions
and here you can add filters and here
you can refine your keywords and we're
going to have a look at that in a minute
up here you can specify the country
yep so we've got United Kingdom you can
say where do you want to search for and
here you put in the period and that is
in this case January to December 2022.
so that is sort of the high level
interface when it comes to getting ideas
for keywords so let's go back and do a
bit more
details on this yes so let me take a
word like t-shirt t-shirt and what are
the ideas that I'm getting and I click
here get results so here now I'm getting
a whole range of ideas
yeah on keywords
so now there may be keywords that I
don't want in here yeah so this is where
I can specify and refine my keywords so
here I can say do Branch or non-branded
so I don't want any keywords in relation
to specific Brands so I can take those
out yes so your Nike keywords are gone
yes so your Adidas keywords are gone so
it is a lot more specific now
yes so you can also say for instance I
don't want t-shirts with no I don't want
Playboy t-shirts yeah so what I can do I
can go to filters I can add a filter and
here I can say exclude
in this case keyword text does not
contain white for instance yep so that
will means it will take all the t-shirts
out where the word white comes in
yep so that is how you can get your
speed more specific with your keywords
and filter them to be more specific and
more relevant for you all right so what
you can then do you can actually select
a few of the keywords
that you say hey these are relevant for
me and you can say okay I am going to
put them in a plan I can put them in an
existing plan or I can put them in a new
plan I can put them into an ad group yep
or I can also look at the match type for
those keywords yeah so I can put them as
broad match phrase match and exact match
and then I can add keywords to create my
plan okay I can copy the keywords
there's more that I can do I can add
them as negative keywords yeah so those
are kind of the functionalities that you
have when you search for your keywords
so let's have a look now at do a bit
more on your keywords when it comes to
competition and when it comes to long
tail so let's close this let's do a
search on keywords for the term e-bike
yep so I'm going to get my results
and what I want to do I want to look for
the keyword with a low competition
yeah so here you see the high
competition and the low competition I
can sort them going up and going down
yes I'm going to so it's a low
and now remember this competition is for
ads yeah so this is not competition for
your search engine optimization
yeah so here when you look at low
competition keywords look at this one
you have stealth bomber e-bike here you
see that is a very popular keyword with
low competition which has a year on year
change of 900 percent
yeah so that is how you can find your
trending keywords yeah so this could be
a very relevant keyword for you yep so
there is also your three months change
so you can look at seasonal keywords
so I can also search for the term for
instance holiday sweater
get results
yeah and if I now look at my three
months change I can look at seasonal
keywords here so look at this Pull and
Bear Christmas sweater holiday sweater
ugly Christmas sweater yeah funny so
here you see the treaders specifically
when it comes to to seasonal patterns so
important that you identify those as
well
yeah now how do you find lucrative
keywords you're going to look at the top
of page bit Yeah and see if they have a
commercial value so what you do is
you're going to look at the top of page
bit high range yeah and from low so here
you see we go back to high range
yep so here you see that these terms
like the Bowden Christmas sweater has a
fairly high top of page price yeah so a
bit price which means there is a good
commercial value for this sweater which
also means that you could then use that
for your SEO because a lot of people
will be searching for that keyword so
there's a high commercial value and then
it's good for your
organic ranking so lots of features that
you can get here out of your Google
Keyword Planner
okay so now that you've understand the
basics of Google Keyword Planner let's
have a look at some tips that will give
you more functionality in the Google
Keyword Planner so one of the big issues
that I have with Google Keyword Planner
is the fact that my average monthly
searches are in a range between here for
example
ebook I didn't want ebook I wanted ebike
yeah so that this is range so between 10
and 100
000 average monthly searches now that
range is so wide that doesn't do
anything for me so how can I bring exact
average monthly searches into my Google
Keyword Planner now there's two ways of
doing that the first way of doing that
is go to the forecast section for the
with the word e-bike for instance yep
and I'm going to add a keyword and I'm
going to type ebike
yep I'm going to add the keyword to the
ad Group which is test I'm clicking
create and I'm going to save my keyword
now here you see what the details is
that you get here so I can get based on
this data uh here you see the average
cost per acquisition number of clicks
but what I want to do here I want to
look at not the maximize conversions but
I want to look at the maximize clicks
and I'm going to apply that
yeah I'm going to put it into a slightly
bigger
let's have a look here yeah so here I
have the data so here you see I can get
two conversions
440 pounds with a five per pound average
daily budget now what I'm gonna do here
I'm going to click on the highest price
the highest budget that I would spend of
this of let's say 520 and let's see how
that changes my data so then here you
see that with this highest price
for the term e-bike yeah I can get about
30 000 impressions
and because I took the highest price
that would be giving me the highest
number impressions of Impressions so I
could say that on average the e-bike for
this period the monthly number of
Impressions that you would get would be
thirty thousand yeah so that is a way to
get more exact search volumes for your
keywords
another way of getting average monthly
search details is by using an external
tool called keyword everywhere keyword
everywhere is basically for Google
search so if I type in e-bike here in
Google search it will give me
search volumes here in under the Search
terms and I can see additional keywords
as well but once I've activated it
yeah so I'm gonna switch it on yeah so
to get these details I can now go back
to my keyword ideas if I do a refresh
and because I've activated the Google
Chrome plugin I go back to discover new
keywords I type in e-bike I'm getting
the results and see what I'm getting now
I'm getting exact volumes I'm getting
cost per click I'm getting competition
and I get trends for that keyword or
those keywords as well so this all of a
sudden adds a lot of value to your
Google Keyword Planner when it comes to
the monthly search volumes so a very
powerful tool now it basically works on
the basis of credits that you buy each
keywords that it shows you the search
volumes is costing you one credit
yeah and you buy hundred thousand
credits for ten dollars that basically
gives you one hundred thousand keywords
as part of your research so it is a good
deal I think to get the credits for your
keyword everywhere too
okay so that is how to unlock search
volumes in Google Keyword Planner let's
look at the let me switch it off to go
back to the core functionality switching
off keywords everywhere let's do a
refresh yeah so we're going to discover
new ideas we're going back to the e-bike
and we're gonna see that I can make my
search results local yeah with the local
Dimension so here I can type United
Kingdom but I can make my locations more
specific so I can also say for instance
let's do London yes so I now have United
Kingdom and London so I'm going to take
United Kingdom out and I now have
london-based search volumes yep so
that's what you can get by changing the
location I'm going to look at the
popularity of search locations so I'm
going to look at forecasts I'm going to
let's say ADD test is the keyword the ad
group here I'm going to type in Super
Bowl okay I'm going to click save and
I'm going to change the location to the
United States okay and don't need the
United Kingdom so I'm going to click
save
yeah so here I'm getting my conversion
data but if I scroll down then here you
can see what are the top states when it
comes to using that keywords
yep so that is a really powerful way to
look at
locations you could also be even more
specific I can hear say okay give me zip
codes for instance here so you can
search by ZIP codes as well and you can
see how the popularity is around zip
code
so finally what you can do here as well
is to look at the various devices that
people are using for those Search terms
okay so that is it what I want to share
with you on Google Keyword Planner
you've seen the basic operation and I
also gave you some ways to get
additional functionality and
particularly ways to get more detailed
search volumes
so now that you've seen all the ins and
outs of Google Keyword Planner its
functionality and how to overcome some
of its shortcomings let's close with
giving you some tips and tricks on using
Google Keyword Planner first of all make
sure you use Broad and specific match
types when you enter your keywords to
get as wider range of keywords possible
in your in your keyword lists also make
sure that you research your competition
just go to enter the website of your
competition and see what keywords come
up with that your competitors may be
using that you have forgotten so you can
then take those keywords and get
additional keyword ideas around those
keywords that your competition is using
make use of negative keywords I
explained negative keywords earlier yeah
keywords like jobs like free like
promotion yeah filter those out in your
in your keyword lists so you have the
best sort of Clicks in your Google ads
Google Keyword Planner is not the only
tool combine your keyword data with
other tools like semrush or HH ah refs
and like the keywords everywhere tool
that I explained to you and how that can
enrich the data you have in your Google
Keyword Planner and then finally
experiment with different keywords and
AD groups while you're running your
campaign Google will give you campaign
results it will give you suggestions it
will give you the most popular keywords
that people are using so every time
check your campaign settings and your ad
groups and your keywords and you may
want to fine tune those
in today's video we are going to be
talking about how to start a blog and
we'll be discussing what is a block what
is a blog post should you start a blog
how do you start a blog and what are the
pros and the cons of blogging in the
process of presenting all this to you I
will share some interesting blogs with
you and I will also share some cool
tools that you can use in developing
your blog setting up your blog and
writing your blog post but before all
this I am Mark Mark campman I'm your
digital navigator for this video and if
you like the video press the like button
and of course if you want to subscribe
to our Channel click on the Subscribe
button below so are you ready let me
start with giving you a few facts about
blogs did you know that there are over
more than 600 million blogs on the
internet
over 2 million blog posts are published
every day
77 of Internet users they regularly read
blogs and articles that include visuals
like photos or Graphics or videos they
in general get up over 90 percent more
views than those articles without
visuals
when it comes to blogging platforms one
of the most popular popular blogging
platforms is Tumblr over
495 million blogs but for businesses
they it is not used that much there are
the more popular platforms for
um for businesses and WordPress is one
of them there are 60 million blogs
powered by WordPress
and blogs are the second most common
form of media used in content marketing
yeah so some really exciting facts about
blogging and about the the number of
blocks on the internet but let's dive
right into it and let's go into what are
we going to be talking about first of
all what does a blog stand for yeah so
let's discuss that in the context of the
timeline of the history of blogs so
blogs they sort of emerged around just
when the internet came about in 1994
1995 and there was a guy called Justin
Hall he started a personal blog while he
was studying at say a college in America
becoming one of the first widely read
bloggers
in the late 90s when the internet was a
bit more accepted the first blogs are
created primarily serving as personal
journals for a small group of friends or
for your family
in the early 2000s blogging tools and
blogging Services became widely
available and this is also when I had my
first exposure to blogs when my son went
on a gap year and he traveled to Asia to
Vietnam and to um to Cambodia and he
uploaded his photos in internet's Cafe
said he found in those countries for his
travel blog so it made it very easy in
those early days for people to create
and maintain their own blog in 2002 the
term blog was coined and became widely
used to describe a website that serves
as an online journal or diary and that's
where the term blog came from like it
was a a web log it was a big log it was
a big web it helps you to read the web
yeah so different angles but the overall
term block becomes used to describe a
website side that serves as an online
journal or a diary so a web log is kind
of the closest to what a Blog really
stands for
so it then started to become very
popular in the sort of the
2005-2010 era when it started to be
picked up by businesses as well the wide
range of topics and styles from personal
journals to photography blogs to recipe
blogs and people really started to see
the power of blogging and in 2010 and
onwards it became a mainstream form of
communication and self-expression with
millions of blogs covering every
possible subject and serving every
possible audience and businesses really
jumped on this and today it is one of
the most significant roles being played
by blogs in the rise of social media and
it has a profound impact on the way
people communicate and consume
information online
yeah so that is a short introduction of
blogging let's have a quick look at what
we're going to be talking about first
I'm going to be digging into a Blog what
is a Blog and then what is a blog post
and what are the characteristics of blog
posts because clearly a Blog and a blog
post is different than a default or a
standard web page next question is that
we're going to answer should you start a
blog yeah some people they are excited
about blogging and they go straight into
it where other people they're not quite
sure yeah so let me give you some tips
and guidelines if you want to start a
blog and when you want to start it how
do you start a blog so that's what we'll
be looking at as well and then we'll
close today's session with a look at the
pros and cons of starting a blog and in
the meantime in the process of
presenting all this I will share with
you lots of tools lots of suggestions
and lots of ideas on starting your own
blog
so let's talk about the features of a
Blog what is a Blog now a blog is a type
of website serving as an online journal
or a diary
and the block consists of a number of
posts on a particular topic or a theme
okay so that is it's a blog post it's
kind of the container for a range of
Articles around a particular theme now
it can be created by individuals it can
be created by companies by businesses
organizations serving various purposes
it could be for personal expression of
ideas it could be for marketing it could
be for journalism or even for activism
the beauty about the blog is that it is
so easily created and managed using
blogging software or blogging services
and all that software and all those
services are available online some are
for free some are premium but it is very
easy to get started with your blog and
those blogging software platforms they
include features such as commenting
systems so that allows you to get your
engagement with your readers
so it is based as a standalone website
or on social media networks or content
Management Systems yep so there's
different ways that you can set up your
blog but it places significant rise in
the growth of um uh in the growth of
social media and as a profound impact on
the way people communicate and the way
people consume information
so then what is a blog post a blog post
is any article any news piece or guide
that is published in the blog section of
website
okay so it typically covers a specific
topic or topic or a query and it's in
the educational in nature and it ranges
from 600 to 2 000 two and a half
thousand words
the typical blog includes the title
title is very important the title
conveys the topic of the post
it then has a body of text with in-depth
information and commentary on the topic
it then has images or multimedia
elements like video or infographics to
illustrate a content and it's very
important to visualize what you're
trying to say in your blog post
other important elements of your blogs
are hyperlinks to other resources that
you use to form your opinion about what
you're writing about
and very important because when you have
a Blog you will have many articles so
you want to give people access to all
those articles as well and EC access so
they use in blocks they use categories
or tags to categorize and organize all
the blog posts and you can search in
those categories search in those tags to
access other blog posts
good blogs also contain a commenting
system for reader feedback there are
sharing buttons for social media sharing
there's a publication date and there is
also a short byline of the author with a
biography or a description yeah so those
are the typical characteristics of a
blog post that you will find in any blog
so as I said earlier a blog post
incorporates visual elements like photos
videos infrastographics even interactive
charts to make the topic that is being
written about come to life to explain a
topic or answer a question and they are
very important because first of all they
grab your attention
yeah because visuals are more
eye-catching than text and can quickly
grab the reader's attention making them
more likely to continue to read a post
visuals also help you to break up the
texts large block of text
can be quite overwhelming for readers so
when you add visuals in between those
large blogs it becomes more visually
appealing
it also helps in explaining the topic so
people have a better understanding of
what you're trying to talk about visuals
can help you illustrate complex Concepts
and ideas so it's easier to understand
but also easier to retain
another important aspect of visuals is
that you can evoke emotions particularly
when you are using video in your blog
post as well so it makes the reading
experience more engaging more memorable
Google likes it as well when you have
visuals or videos in your blog post it
really helps you with your search engine
optimization
yes so it's easier for readers to find a
post than in search engines yeah like
Google or Bing or Yahoo
and then finally visuals they play a
crucial role in enhancing the reader's
experience and make the blog post more
effective in presenting and explaining
and conveying the information and ideas
a really good
um
blog that uses visuals in a very good
way is social media examiner.com yeah I
really like social media examiner it's a
typical blog it is almost like not
recognizable as a Blog website but it is
based on a huge collection of Articles
covering all topics around social media
and to access their library or visual
posts you go to the about us and here
you have the range of articles on web3
on Instagram marketing Facebook
marketing YouTube marketing so let's go
to Instagram marketing and immediately
you see
all the content around Instagram yep and
if I go to one of their blog posts how
to use Instagram for business then you
see immediately there is a visual that
explains the overall blog post and what
it is all about yep and then it uses
visuals as well in the blog post to make
it very clear and explain exactly how
things work and how you should use
specific functionality with links to
other tools and tools resources yeah so
it has a really good visual appeal
making it very easy for subscribers to
consume the content
okay so that is what a blog post in
general is about yep so let's look at a
few more details here yeah another very
important aspect of a Blog is the
writing style
yeah blog posts are typically written in
conversational style or in personal size
style or in
um informal style yeah so blog posts
they should have a conversational or an
informal tone as if the writer is
speaking directly to the reader because
that makes it more relatable and more
engaging it's also personal so includes
personal anecdotes personal experience
personal opinions and add a unique human
touch to the blog post you therefore use
an active voice yeah instead of passive
voice so we talk about I think we want
to do this instead of they think they
want to do that
so make it clear and concise which is
allowing it to be easy to read and
understand use Simple language try to
avoid technical jargon
another important aspect of the writing
is the attention grabbing headline it's
a headline that is attention grabbing
clearly articulates what the content of
the post is all about and it encourages
people to read the blog post
people love headings of blog posts or
titles of blog posts with numbers five
things you should do to achieve this or
four things you may have missed
yet then there is this the spirographs
and the subheadings make them short
break the text up in short paragraphs
and use those subheadings for the is to
make it easier for the reader to scan
the article as well and then a very
important aspect of your blog is to make
sure that you have engaging calls to
action
yeah a strong and compelling call to
action can encourage readers to engage
with your content and you can ask for
those call to actions ask people to
comment ask people to share or ask
people to take some other action like
signing up for the blog or signing up
for a newsletter
yes so now of course there is no fixed
method of writing your blog make sure
that you write your blog to the style of
your audience
yes so be flexible you meet the specific
needs of your target audience
now a key question of course should you
start a blog
yeah some people are natural writers and
it makes sense for them to start a blog
some people haven't got a clue but
they're very passionate about something
yeah and the more passionate you are
about something the easier it will be
for you to share your thoughts and ideas
but before I go into more detail in this
question let's have a look at some of
the most popular blog categories and
let's have some uh look at some example
blocks that really stand out so there
are many popular blog titles but here
are some of the most popular topics
first of all there are lifestyle blogs
It's Fashion Beauty Health Wellness
travel and food are very popular they
arrange for a wide appeal and makes it
very personal and very relevant for
readers
second is technology box people love
technology blogs it has always stuff to
write about technology because it
changes so fast there's always news
there's always something exciting to
write whether it's smartphones whether
it's laptops whether it's artificial
intelligence or whether it's virtual
reality
another category that's very popular is
blogs about personal finance helping
people to better understand and manage
their finances with topics ranging from
savings and investing to debt management
and budgeting
Business and Entrepreneurship blogs they
are really cool they're really hot on
the internet whether you want to start a
new business when you want to grow an
existing business there's a huge demand
for information and advice on topics
around Business and Entrepreneurship
various obvious very obvious topic to
blog about is news and current affairs
blogs that cover the latest news and
current affairs they are always popular
whether they focus on a particular area
of Interest like politics or technology
or cover a broad range of topics
then there is creative writing there's
literature those are blogs for writers
for readers blogs about creative writing
and literature where you can get a great
source of inspiration and connection
and then finally there's personal
development and self-improvement blocks
topics like personal growth self-care
self-improvement Health they're very
popular for their relevance to many
people's lives
so these are some of the most popular
block Target topics now there are many
many more the possibilities are endless
but the best topics are often those
topics that align with the blorish
passion and expertise
So within those categories let's have a
look at some really good blogs so we
have here an example block a Beautiful
Mess
which is a personal what was it a um a
lifestyle blog yeah so here you see all
the articles in a very simple graphical
presentation you see the color the theme
that is being used is really good it's a
very sort of mellow mellow color tone
yeah they are linking it to a shop as
well here are brands that they work with
but here you see the typical articles
how to cut a pineapple step by step with
video now the typical example of a
really good title for a blog post it's
how to people love how-to titles it is
step by step so we'll make it easy and
it has a video as well yeah that
explains how to do it so again here you
see the title here you see the author
you can pin it straight on Pinterest you
can jump straight to the recipe here is
some proof social proof yeah here you
can subscribe to the blog you see that
in many blogs the right column is being
used for things like subscribe or access
to categories or
um two tags yeah here you see the blog
post itself here you see hyperlinks to
other articles yep and here are links to
other articles as well and these are
often blogs in blog posts in this blog
as well with strong visuals
yep and then there should be the video
as well because there wasn't a video
that explains it as well yeah so let us
say really good I really like this blog
very simple linking it to a Hot Topic
today Valentine's Day that is coming up
here is a technology Blog The Verge
totally different more male it's black
and white yeah it is strong it's
powerful very good branding that fits
the technology but the same contact
concept blocks strong visuals a um good
titles yep and then here you have how to
access other blog posts as well which
are the top stories yeah the most
popular articles here is a stream that
you can get
yep so here is another stream so very
useful powerful blog and here you have
the categories that they are blogging
about
Business and Entrepreneurship
again another block example very content
driven lots of articles but categorized
in a very logical way money and finance
business news Science and Technology
yeah and here is the latest articles
that we've just added another category
buying investing in business another
category branding yes so really good
accessible content in these these blogs
finally the one the last one I want to
show you is tiny Buddha simple wisdom
for complex life so this is clearly a
personal development and
self-improvement blog
yeah here is the latest from the blog
here is some fun and inspiring thoughts
here is to subscribe subscribe and um to
the blog here you see the categories
that they have yep and then here you see
the different blog posts so let's look
at the typical article yeah so here you
have the basic article here is the
headline the the title here is the
visual here's the blog post itself
people love bullets in blog posts people
love lists
yeah links to other articles we talked
about the um the author a little
biography and then here you see the
right hand column yeah there is a bit of
subscribe there is a search of the blog
content and then here is a download a
desktop wallpaper recent topics
yep and then the latest post so typical
format of a very powerful blog post
so yeah so these are just some examples
of some really good blogs yeah that are
covering a wide range of topics
now that should give you some ideas and
some food for thought about whether or
not you should start a blog
so let's dive a bit deeper
first of all you should have a passion
for writing and sharing on a particular
topic
yeah so you should have a passion about
a topic it should be your hobby or you
should just want to know learn
everything about a particular topping so
because you know when there is a when
you start blogging in fact is it does
take a considerable amount of time and
effort not only to start a blog but also
to maintain it so it's important that
you have a genuine interest in the topic
you want to write about
yeah also you need to have very clear
goals what do you want to achieve with
your blog post or with your blog yeah is
it for driving traffic to your website
is it to become known as an expert is it
just for a hobby yeah do you want to
build a personal brand do you want to
use it for your business
yes so or do you maybe want to build an
online following or an online community
or do you want to document your personal
Journey or progress around a specific
project like your garden that you're
your house that you're developing or a
holiday that you are having
so all these things can are can be very
important in your decision making
whether or not you should start a blog
but if these are all positive and if you
are very convinced and dedicated from
yes I'm going to start a blog yep then
blogging is a fantastic opportunity for
you
and when you are a business there are so
many advantages so many benefits that
you can get from having a Blog on your
website
it can help you in driving traffic to
your website yeah and the traffic that
comes to your website they will read
your blog post and they will Ex they
will see you more and more as an expert
in your field and it will help you in
turning those web visitors into
prospects so you drive conversions
blogging in my opinion is the easiest
way to kick start your social media
yeah what is the process you start up
your blog you write a blog post and then
you share that blog post on Twitter on
LinkedIn on Facebook on Instagram yeah
in different formats and you're going to
make sure that your blog title and your
blog visual is on as many places on the
internet as possible
people will see the blog post and if
they like it they will click on it and
that will take them to your website and
not only that Google will see your blog
post as well and will put your article
higher up in the search engine result
page
so in doing all this you build trust you
can build client relationships in a much
better way it helps you in reinforcing
your brand and it helps you in
differentiating yourself from your
competitors and encourage engagement
with your followers
so now that you understand the basics of
blogging and what a blog post is and
whether or not you should start a blog
let's look into the actual process of
starting a blog what are the things that
you need to look at what are the things
that you need to take into consideration
first of all before you start your blog
you need to understand who you're
writing for
yeah you need to research your target
audience what would they like to learn
more about what are their pain points
what are their interests because you can
write whatever you want but if nobody
reads it yeah then it's not going to
serve you any purpose
in marketing terms we talk about
customer personas you should make
customer personas for your audience
let's have a look here there is a really
good tool which is HubSpot
personas
yeah it's from uh from
HubSpot a make my Persona tool so I just
want to share that with you yeah there
are two elements there is what is a
buyer Persona and there's also a tool
make my Persona so let's talk about what
is a buyer Persona a buyer Persona is a
semi-fictional representation of your
ideal customer based on Market Research
looking on the internet talking to your
colleagues your two sales people or
talking to your customers themselves and
real data that you can find about your
customers and in your case you can
actually change customer with reader who
is your ideal reader reader and what do
you know about the reader
you're then going to look at why do I
need this your day provide structure
Persona they provide structure and
context for you as the Blogger making it
easier for you to map out the content
yeah and align your topics with the
requirements the reading needs of your
audience
yeah and how do you use them yes so by
learning about your ideal customer or
your ideal reader their challenges their
goals their demographic traits it helps
you set up a Content strategy
yeah which will increase the chance that
people will read your blog so how do you
create a Persona there's lots of tools
on the internet you can download a guide
here yeah you can also go to back to
um the tool here make my Persona and
that is on HubSpot there is actually a
tool where they can help you build a
persona yeah it will ask you a set of
questions
yeah Show created an avatar name your
persona and then it looks at some
demographic characteristics it looks at
some
um some was it characterizations it
looks at both radio challenges how do
they consume information you can do that
in a walk through mode or you can also
skip the walkthrough mode and then you
go actually into the final version of
the Persona that you can hear filling in
here as well yep so they want to know
where to name the title the age level of
Education the social networks that
they're using or reading what is their
preferred method of communication what
are their responsibilities what are the
goals of and objectives what is the
biggest challenge and you can tailor
this completely to your own sort of
reader profile
very useful tool on creating customer
personas a very important part on
starting your blog
once you've started your and created
your persona you're then going to check
out your competition
what are your competitors posting about
yeah how do they approach their target
audience what are the typical topics
that they are looking for yes so now
there's different ways of finding blocks
from your competitors yeah the
traditional way I would go to Google
yep and I would just search for instance
if I'm in CRM yeah I would just search
on the top 10
blogs on CRM
yep and then here you get lists in
Google of the top CRM blocks yes so and
then you're just gonna have a look at
those blogs you're gonna analyze their
content you're going to look at the
topics the formats the tone and the
style you're going to check if we can
get some information about traffic their
social media following their engagement
and maybe you can find gaps in the
content that they are using yep so there
and that those gaps in the content they
are opportunities for you and maybe you
can look at their promotions that
they're running to gather ideas for your
own blog now you may have heard recently
of a new tool that is out there and that
is getting very a lot of traction in the
uh in the industry yeah it is a tool
called chat GPT and I had it open
somewhere let me have a look here I
don't think I have let's just go to chat
opening ai.com
which is a new tool which is what we
call conversational
artificial intelligence
and the whole industry is talking about
it it basically has the potential to
replace Google but time will tell yes so
don't need that yeah so it is basically
conversational
artificial intelligence instead of going
to Google and search for give me the top
10 blogs here I'm just going to ask give
me the top five CRM blogs
yeah and reasons why
they are
so popular
let's see what it comes up with
yeah so you see I'm asking two questions
here give me the top five CRM blocks but
also reasons why they are popular
so this is a whole new way of exploring
content on the internet
and I'm sure in the future we're going
to be using and running a a video where
we're explaining chat GPT in more detail
and how you can use it as a marketeer
but
um in the meantime make sure you have a
look at this and look and start using it
for some of the topics that you are
looking at at the moment
yes so really useful really powerful
watch that space on chat GPT yeah so
really good to use it to analyze your
competition
so once you've got your competition
analyzed you're then going to decide
what are the topics that you're going to
cover you're going to look at the focus
area of your blog it's very important if
you want to be successful with your blog
so here are some steps that you can go
through first of all you identify your
passion
you're identifying your interests yeah
so that's where you can sort of in
initially start at looking at the topics
that you want to cover you're then going
to look at okay who is my audience yeah
you're going to create your personas and
then you've looked at your competition
as well but then very important once
you've looked and identified a topic you
then need to check is is it popular is
it trending
because yeah you can write a top topic
about a fantastic subject but if nobody
is reading about it if nobody is talking
about it yeah then hey it what's it
gonna do for you so a really good tool
to look at what is trending in the world
at the moment is a tool called Google
Trends
so you just saw Chet's GPT which is
conversational AI so let's have a look
at is conversational AI a Hot Topic on
the internet Google Trends is a tool
that will give you how entrance about
how many people are searching for those
terms and the more people are searching
for it of course the more people are
interested about it the more exciting it
is and if I look at this term
from 2004 till today
yeah then you see immediately how hot
conversational artificial intelligence
is becoming and then particularly here
in the last couple of months this was
the November 2022 was when chat GPT
launched its pre its product
and here you see the Stellar growth
on the topic yes so use conversation use
Google Trends to find out if your topic
is hot if your topic is trending
good so once you've looked at the
trending of your topic is it popular
you're then going to find your angle yes
so that is a key factor because there's
so many ways you can write about
conversational AI but what are the
topics or the subtopic what is the angle
that you're going to take
so basically to find out about the
angles on your topics then you of course
need to understand your Niche you need
to have a good understanding of your
Niche and the topics within your niche
again you're looking at your competitors
yeah so if there is a a certain sub
Niche yeah or a subtopic but everybody
has been writing about this then that is
not going to help you so you want to
find those areas within your Niche that
have not been explored yet
can look at your readers what do they
want to hear about what do okay you can
then adapt your writing to your readers
requirements and do simple things use
your own experiences and perspectives in
analyzing what you're going to write
about that can really help you in
finding a unique angle that sets you
apart from your competitors and
challenge yourself challenge the status
quo ask yourself questions that other
bloggers may not be asking be critical
but make sure that you found that unique
angle that you want to go for
right so now that we know the topic now
that we know the angle we're going to
start the block so the first thing we
need to do is to come up with a name for
the blog
yeah when you start thinking about
naming your blog you make sure you it is
descriptive
so make sure that the name of your blog
accurately describes the focused content
of your blog because that makes it
easier for the reader to understand what
your blog is all about
keep it simple don't use underscores or
hyphens keep the name simple avoid
overly complicated names that are
difficult to spell or remember
try to make your name unique yes so make
sure that your name sets you apart from
others in your niche think about SEO if
there's keywords that you can put in
your name of your blog yeah that can
really help
also very important to check if there is
a um if the URL is available for the
name of your blog because it's a
fantastic name but if there's no URL
available and I'll come back to that in
a minute and then of course ask people
ask Friends Ask customers what do you
think about the name of this blog and
use tools there's lots of naming tools
for your blogs yeah for for websites but
again if I go to chat GPT and I'll just
say give me 10 names for my new
CRM blog
chat GPT is going to give you fantastic
answers
yeah it just gives you ideas
so guys this chat GPT is going to
revolutionize the marketing profession
in the next few years and there's so
much more to come in this space
okay so that's where you go and have
your name for your blog and then check
the URL for the blog as well yeah so
once you've created your blog name you
need to create your blog domain and the
first thing you're going to do is is the
name available yes so
so here is a simple tool name Checker
and you can just type in the name so go
here to the name that we had yes so
let's say CRM Franca
and then we're going to go to
namechecker here we're typing CRM
Frontier
yep and we're just going to check is it
available as a.com
is it available on Facebook no is it
available on Twitter on Tumblr and you
see all the social channels and the.com
if it is available yeah and once it is
available you know it you're then going
to a
um a URL sort of place where you can buy
URLs and then you can
um go to your check if the name is
available there and you can go and buy
it so but we'll come back to that in a
minute so this is choose your name yeah
and make sure that your name is
available so then you're going to your
domain registrar so let's go to for
instance GoDaddy
yep so CRM Frontier is the name that we
wanted
so I'm going to put in the domain
see again if it is available search
domain
yeah and here you see CRM Frontier is
available for 7 14 and it's also
available as dot Co dot UK but you also
may want to look at am I going to use
dot info or Dot online or dot Inc or dot
TV so all the sessions that you need to
make the guideline here is that if you
are targeting a global market try to go
for the.com domain if you're targeting a
local market go for the domain of that
country like dot Co dot UK for the UK
yeah or dot ca for Canada yes so
different ways of doing that but that is
the Golden Rule so we've checked
availability you can now register your
domain and then of course once you've
set up your blog you need to connect
your domain to your blog
good so that is the domain and the
domain registration
so if we go on the next thing you need
to do is choose a Content management
system
for your blog which is a very important
step in setting up your online presence
because with your CMS you actually
create your blog gone are the days where
you need to program in HTML yeah you now
have very simple blogging platforms like
WordPress or Wix yeah that can help you
in creating your website very important
in the decision for your CMS consider
the features that you need like blog
post creation blog post management user
management integration with other tools
and look at the important popular CMS
systems like WordPress or blogger or Wix
or Squarespace research them yep and
then ask jet GPT maybe which one that
you want to use look at ease of use yeah
there are free versions there are
premium versions check for support is
very important make sure that the
support as a chat availability that is
so much better when it comes to
productivity looks at at scalability and
look at cost as well a lot of web TMS
systems they may offer you a free
version to start with but then it will
have some basic advertising or you can't
use your own URL so very important that
you choose a CMS that works for you now
one of the most popular cms's that you
can use is WordPress WordPress be aware
there are two versions of Wordpress
there is wordpress.com
which is a web development platform
which is hosted by WordPress so you
don't have to go to a provider like
GoDaddy and set up your website this is
all being done on WordPress
wordpress.com is the easiest platform to
get started with your own blog and
literally you can have your blog up and
running within 10 minutes
if you want to have a more professional
setup a more
um
long lasting a more powerful setup you
would go to wordpress.org and
wordpress.org you can only use through a
web internet service provider like
GoDaddy where you basically rent a
specific set of storage yep and that is
where you can install your own WordPress
installation
so that is wordpress.com and
wordpress.org so very important
decisions on starting your own WordPress
or your own development platform
and then finally you need to look at the
look and feel of your blog how are you
going to customize this so you need to
choose a theme for your blog yes so
because that can make or break your blog
and many blogging platforms they one of
the first questions they will ask you
what theme would you like to use for
your blog and let me show you very
simple one of the leading theme
platforms for your blog is envato yeah
there is theme forest seamforest.net and
you see here there's a whole library of
themes that you can choose for instance
I can say give me
um
a Blog magazine yeah or give me other
topics yes so go back to all categories
so let's say let's go for a photography
blog
photography WordPress blog and then here
I'm getting a whole library of Wordpress
themes there are premium themes and
there are free themes as well but let's
take this first one
I can actually get a live preview of
that blog
yeah and then you see how the blog would
look like here you see the demos so
there would be demo one
yeah would be this one here
yeah so now it's actually loading this
theme and this is how your blog will
look like
yeah let's um close this one here
so here you see yeah you don't need this
one on the side here
but here you can see how the blog would
look like
so
yep so really useful way of looking at
the deciding on the theme that you want
to use for your blog yeah so here you
see the how the block would look
and then what you do when you go to
Wordpress you load the theme you load
the demo as well and then basically your
website is ready and the only thing you
have to do is change the photos change
the text and sort of tailor it to your
own visual Style
so there you have it very important yes
so
looking at the customization of your
blog by using themes that you can buy on
the internet out of a free or for a
premium
okay now I hope you have enough
knowledge now to make the decision
whether or not you're going to start a
blog let me give you a bit more details
about what is good about blogging what
is bad about blogging good about
blogging ish it's a great way to express
yourself and a great way to share your
thoughts yeah it is really good to help
you build expertise if you write
consistently about your topic or your
industry your customers will start
recognizing you as an expert in your
field and Google as well so you can
really use all that to build your
personal brand and on the back of that
promote your company
a blog is a really good platform to
build engagement with your following
through the commenting for instance or
through uh subscribing to your blog and
therefore it can build really good
networking opportunities for you and
connect with other bloggers and other
industry professionals so lots of
benefits that you can get from starting
a blog but there are negatives as well
don't think that when you start a blog
then that is a piece of cake and it's
going to take no time it takes time yeah
you need to commit to it and the worst
thing is that you start a blog and then
after three or four blog posts the blog
turns dead and then there's no updates
to your blog yes so be committed to the
time that you want to put into this
it'll take time it's technical you need
to unless you go for a simple platform
like wordpress.com or Wix where you
don't have to worry about the technical
setup if you want to do it
professionally for your business you
need to have some technical
understanding on how to choose a
platform a hosting and the design of
your web
and the more technical it gets the more
costs are involved as well because with
the web hosting the domain name the
design and the security on your website
as well and getting your
um yeah so getting your uh your various
security certificates on your web
make sure that it's consistent you need
to be consistent with your content yeah
and keep your audience engaged and be
aware there is lots of competition out
there when you launch a block it doesn't
mean that all of a sudden everybody now
recognizes you as a blogger it takes
time it takes effort it takes
consistency yeah and it also it makes
sure that you stand out with your blog
from your competition now let me tell
you about simply lens postgraduate
program in digital marketing created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint with this program you
will learn everything from the
fundamentals of digital marketing to the
latest trends and techniques used by top
marketers worldwide you will explore SEO
sem content marketing social media
marketing email marketing and more this
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world if you're
looking to jump start your career
digital marketing or take your skills to
the next level then simply learns
professional certificate program in
digital marketing is the perfect place
to start to learn more about the course
you can click the link in the
description box below I'll tell you
about what is your blog about what are
the skills you need to start blogging
why should you start blogging and how do
you start blog from the very scratch but
before that I am Mark campman I'm going
to be your digital navigator for this
video and if you would like to subscribe
to our YouTube channel don't forget to
click the Subscribe button below so
let's get started blogging for beginners
let me give you a few facts and figures
about blogs before we dive into the
topic did you know that there are more
than 600 million blogs on the internet
and every day over 2 million blog posts
are published on all those blog posts
that are out there 77 of Internet users
they read blog and they leave about
77 million comments per month on all
these blog posts so it is a massive
um place where you can get engagement
and where you can get people talking
about the things that you're writing
about now people that include visuals to
their blogs they will see that they get
about 94 percent more views than those
people that do not add visuals to their
blog surprisingly Tumblr is the most
used blogging platform with over half a
billion blogs out there but there are 60
million blocks that are powered by
WordPress also did you know that blocks
are the second most form of media used
in content marketing so lots about
blogging lots of facts they're out there
they're key they're relevant and this
blog is going to introduce you to how to
get started with a Blog now blogs have
been around for a very long time yeah do
you know what the name of the first
block was and who created it was it A B
C or D well let me give you the answer
Justin Hall started links.net in 1994 as
a student at a at a college becoming one
of the first widely read bloggers out
there in the late 1990s the first blocks
were created primarily serving as
personal journals for small groups of
friends or for family now in the early
2000s blogging tools and services became
more widely available and it is also
when I got my first experience in
blogging when my son went on a on a gap
year traveling in in Southeast Asia and
he shared his photos through the
internet on a on a Blog so he found
internet cafes during his journey and in
each Cafe he started up his blog and
added a photo so that's how I could
follow his his trip so it makes it
became easier and easier for people to
start to create and maintain their own
blogs in 2002 the term blog was coined
and became widely used to describe a
website that serves as an online journal
or a diary so in 2004 the political
world started to get an idea about a
power of blogs they emerged and played a
role in shaping public opinion
influencing selections 2005 to 2010 was
the big growth of blocks and they
started to gain popularity and they came
into sort of the um into the more widely
uh
discussable areas like photography blogs
and recipe blogs and then in the 2010s
businesses got to see the power of blogs
and they started to use blocks as a
mainstream form of communication and for
other people as self-expression with
millions of blogs covering every
possible subject and serving a diverse
range of audiences so today blogging
continues to play a significant role in
the rise of social media and it has a
very big impact on the way people
communicate and consume information
online a fantastic tool to learn to find
out about what's happening in the world
was fine to find out what's happening in
particular niches that you're interested
in and a great way to start sharing your
your own opinion so what will we be
talking about we're going to be talking
about what is a Blog what skills do you
need for blogging why actually should
you create a blog what are the types of
blog posts that you can create and I'm
going to show you some examples of those
different types of blog posts how do you
create a blog and I'm going to give you
some block writing tips to close off
with the uh did on the video today so
let's get into it what is a Blog
now there are many different definitions
of a Blog yeah their blog can be a
personal blog it can be a corporate blog
it can be a news blog yeah so a personal
blog is where it's a type of Vlog where
individuals share their thoughts their
opinions their experiences their their
stories on a particular topic or a
particular range yeah these type of
blogs are very easy to set up and they
don't cost a lot of money but it's very
much with a personal Focus
businesses they usually have corporate
blogs it's a type of block by creating
this by a company and it can be used for
marketing it can be used for Branding it
can be used for communication purposes
for lead generation usually they share
company news they share productive
updates or industry insights yep so it's
also really good to engage with
customers and to get in a dialogue with
customers to build relationships and to
create
um thought expertise in a particular
Niche the third type of blog that you
can see in this definition of a blog is
a news blog it's a type of blog that
focuses on reporting and analyzing
current events current news stories
what's happening in the world from a
particular angle it could be one
journalist it could be a group of
journalists it could be a media
organization yeah and it can cover a
wide range of topics or it can focus on
a particular Niche like entertainment or
like technology so it can be used to
create different perspectives on new
stories or to supplement the traditional
new stories but if we're looking at the
plain definition of a Blog if you look
at all the blogs they work from the same
concept
yeah a blog is a type of website serving
as an online journal or diary
and it consists of posts on a particular
topic or a particular theme yeah now a
Blog can be created by an individual or
by businesses and let's say as I said
earlier they can serve different
purposes for personal or for business or
for news they're very easy to create
blogs and that makes them so powerful
then you can use Simple blogging
software there's lots of free tools
available and you can get started within
five minutes they have lots of features
like commenting yes so and by using the
commenting functions you can allow
engagement with your readers and you can
really build up a community
now you can find blogs on specific
Standalone websites like a Blog website
or you can find them on
embedded within a corporate corporate
website you could even blog on social
media networks like LinkedIn or um or
Facebook
and they often use a Content management
system yep to to create a blog to manage
the blog and to add new content new
pages on your blog
ging for me is the easiest way to get
started with social media yeah so they
played a significant role in the growth
of social media and it had
fundamentally changed the way businesses
communicated with them with their
customers yes so and and how people sort
of consume information
yeah so blogs they have a number of
things in common
yeah so if you go to a Blog each blog
you will see a number of recurring
things the first thing of course that
you see are the blog posts they are the
Articles or the entries written or
published on the blogs and they can be
in different presentation formats yeah
you can see it in little thumbnails you
can see it in the headlines
or you can see just a scroll down of all
the blog posts but the blog posts are
obviously the core of each blog post
blogs have comments you can switch off
the comments if you want but most blogs
they have commenting and they are an
important part of a Blog because they
allow you to engage with the author yeah
or that the author can engage with their
readers so that gives a platform for
discussion for feedback and for
interaction around the blog
yeah when you start blogging you may
have a you may build up a big library of
blogs of blog posts yeah so a common
feature on every blog is that they have
categories and tags yep and you see them
on the column on the right on blog posts
and that means that you can easily
access previous content
so you're not stuck to the main article
but you give people access to other
content through categories through tags
or the most popular posts or the last
five posts blogs also have an about page
what is this blog all about it provides
reader with information about the author
of The Blog yeah the purpose of the blog
the mission of the blog so some
background information good blogs also
have a search box
yeah it's another way where you can
easily search for Content yeah that has
already been published on the blog
now a Blog without sharing buttons yeah
is like you're keeping it a secret so
one of the powerful features of a Blog
is that you as the author can share it
on social media but you can also ask
your readers to share it on social media
by using the sharing buttons then there
is the archive section where it
organizes the post by month by year or
by category again making it easy to
access previous content
and then many blogs have a call to
action
yeah so that is a button that encourages
readers to take a specific action like
subscribing to the blog or downloading
an ebook or signing up for a newsletter
yeah so it's very good tool to start
creating and building your audience
and on top of that you need to think
about the design and the navigation of
your block is very important and we
talked about that in our other blogging
video
um that we posted a few weeks ago yes so
those are the common elements of a Blog
so let's dig a bit deeper we talked
about yeah how a block can be personal
it can be for business it can be news as
long as it is in a specific topic
yes so around that topic or theme you
can start sharing your thoughts sharing
your ideas your knowledge and you can
express yourself so most some of the
most important and in demand topics for
blogs are lifestyle yeah like topics
like Fashion Beauty Health Wellness
travel and food are very popular
they have a very wide appeal and that's
very personal relevance to readers as
well
technology is a very hot topic yeah
showed a vast change of technology and
Innovation technological developments
there's always something to write about
there's always news around technology
yes so that is a very hot topic another
topic is personal finance people love to
know more about how to manage their Pi
finances and blogs can be a really good
way to help the readers and giving them
tips in how to manage their Finance in a
range of topics from savings investing
debt management and budgeting
yet there's blogs about Business and
Entrepreneurship they're very popular
from starting a new business yeah to
growing an existing one how to relate to
your customers there's a huge demand for
top four blocks around the theme of
business and business support
now there's news websites there's news
blogs around current events that cover
the latest news yeah they are popular
they can focus on a particular area like
what's it like politics or technology or
they can cover a more broad range as
well
there's creative blogs creative writing
creative literature writing yes so blogs
that are about creative writing and
about literature they can be a great
source of inspiration
and then finally personal development is
a very big category in blogs a very
popular category yeah personal
development and self-improvement like
personal growth self-care
self-improvement they're really popular
and they are relevant to people's
day-to-day life yeah so these are some
of the most popular blog posts and the
block topics that people
um that people are interested in so for
you start looking into the topics if you
want to start blogging yeah and see if
you can pick a sort of a a topic that is
Within These Within These categories
so
is blogging difficult do I need a wide
range of skills for blogging well it's
not too difficult but of course people
have lots of different questions about
blogging before they start how do I
start a blog how do I come up with ideas
for my blog content how do I get traffic
to my blog how often should I publish on
my blog post
how do I monetize my blog what should I
write about what should I include in my
blog post how do I write an exciting
headline how do I promote my blog on
social media how do I engage with my
readers how do I track the success of my
blog lots and lots of questions yeah and
of course to answer all these questions
you do need to have certain skills
before you start blogging so let's have
a look at those skills
so to be successful with a bloke and to
successfully start a blog there are some
skills that you need
of course you can work on those skills
you can start building up those skills
but these are the five topics
that are
playing an important part of your
blogging work your blogging activity
there's writing
there's search engine optimization
there's marketing there's web design and
there's social media
yeah so first you need to be able to
write
you need to research you need to write
in a clear concise and engaging manner
yep and that is a skill in itself and of
course when you start blogging
you you may not have that much
experience but when you have been
blogging for six months to a year you
will see that it gets easier and easier
the next thing you need to do is to be
able to optimize your blog posts for
search for Google for Bing yeah so that
they those search engines will find your
blog posts when you publish them
yeah and a very important part of your
search engine optimization is to
identify the keywords that are relevant
for your business and they're relevant
for your blog and then you need to
understand how to use those keywords
effectively
then of course you need to Market your
blog you need to grow an audience you
need to get people to subscribe to your
blog maybe to start building an email
list yes so you need to understand email
marketing you need to know online
marketing to promote your blog you need
to know how to do that you need to know
where to do that you may want to look at
affiliate marketing which means you can
promote other people's products on your
blog and you would get a a small
commission for that yes so lots of
marketing activities that you need to
look into to actually to publish your
blog and make it become visible and make
it become popular
now of course there is the web design
element for your blog as well and those
are skills that you need to have there
are very simple tools as you will see
later yeah that you can use to set up
your your blog there are three tools
that you can use there's more advanced
tools as well and as with many things
with the more advanced tools and the
premium tools that you use you get more
quality you get more options you get
often a better design yeah so that is
the balance that you need to strike
between hey how much do I want to do for
free and want to do simple compared to
do you want to invest some money and do
you want to have a more advanced website
yes so that is sort of the balance that
you need to do but you do need to have
some basic web design skills and then
finally you need to have your social
media skills yes social media is a key
part of promoting your blog on the
Social Web and you need to know how to
do that you need to know how to set it
up or you need to know how to create
those social media posts and how to
track them when they um when you have
published them yeah so lots of skills
that you need but it doesn't mean that
you need to be an expert immediately
when you start with that yeah but it is
it is important that you recognize those
topics and that you start building
experience for that
okay so if you feel that you have those
skills
yeah then is that enough for you to
start creating a Blog yeah there's some
other questions that you need to ask
yourself first of all one of the biggest
questions you need to ask there's
yourself is what am I going to write
about
yeah do I have a passion for writing and
sharing my knowledge about a certain
topic do I have a passion about a theme
about a topic am I do I have a passion
about technology do I have a passion
about health yeah so you need to have
that passion because when you start
developing your blog and writing your
blog posts it takes in a it takes time
it takes effort and the more passionate
you are about the topic that you write
about then that time in that effort
doesn't matter you don't feel like it's
taking all that time because you're
doing something that you really really
like
you also need to have very clear goals
yeah what are you going to do with your
blog why are you having this blog you
also need to have the time and the
resources to regularly create new blog
posts
yeah because there's nothing more
frustrating and nothing more damaging on
your website if you start a blog but
then after five posts you stop with it
yeah there's so many websites where you
go to and then you go to the blog and
the last blog post was 24 months ago
yeah then it almost works against you
yeah it shows hey there's a Blog but
they haven't taken the efforts to um to
start a blog
yes so you need to have that passion you
need to have clear goals now businesses
they often have very clear goals for a
Blog yeah they want to use a Blog to
increase traffic to the website to drive
conversions yet to get people through
the website to get them to convert into
a prospect it helps them in contributing
to their social media efforts it's great
way to build client trust to be seen as
an expert in their fields yep it gets a
great way for developing the brand and
reinforce the key messages around the
brand it's great to differentiate
yourself from your competitors and it is
a good way to encourage engagement with
your customers yeah so for businesses
there's almost like a no-brainer they
want to they they use blogs because they
can see that they get a lot of benefits
but for you let's take it very simple
yeah there are five reasons if you want
to start your blog there's five reasons
why you can why you should create a blog
yes first of all if you want to express
yourself creatively then blogging is the
best place to do this
yeah so if you haven't if you are
passionate about a topic and you want to
share that knowledge then blogging is
the number one place to go to yeah
second if you want to show yourself as
an expert or build yourself as an expert
and you want to grow want to grow an
audience around this you want to grow a
follower base who are interested in
learning about what you have to say
about your topic yeah so if you want to
establish expertise and build an
audience then you have to start using a
Blog for that
certainly a reason why you must create a
blog if you want to build a community if
you want to network with other people if
you want to network with prospects get
them to your website get them to convert
yeah if you want that to grow your
business then blogging is certainly a
fantastic vehicle to help you achieve
that another reason to create a blog is
that you want to enhance your writing
and your thinking skills
yes so blogging is not writing a book
blogging is not writing an ebook because
and people may be scared of that it may
be too
um too much of a uh
um an unknown field but start writing
small simple articles on your blog
thereby you develop your writing and you
develop your thinking skills very good
reason for you to start blogging you
don't even have to publish it you can
just keep it your private blog yeah but
then when you feel comfortable you can
then start publishing it
and then finally and that's how I
started as well with my own business if
you want to start making money if you
want to start your own business
you have then a blog is a fantastic
vehicle to help position you in your
markets in your industry
yeah so it's a great vehicle that can
help you to become self-employed or make
more money so lots of reasons for you to
start creating a Blog yes so now that
we've seen what you need yeah for
creating and start blogging yeah why you
should start blogging uh let's have a
look at the different types of blog
posts that you can create on your blog
there are many different types of posts
and I'll give you a list of them in um
in a minute and each blog post each type
of blog post they serve a different
purpose and a different requirement from
the readers but there are some reasons
that
apply to every reader first of all your
blog post must provide value
yeah different readers have different
preferences to the type of content they
like to read but value is the same for
everybody yeah so if you provide value
to your readers you keep them engaged
and very important you keep them coming
back another common characteristics for
book for all blog posts is that you need
to keep them fresh and you need to keep
them interesting
so it means you need to make sure that
the content is up to date but also that
you do a variety of post types because
that keeps it fresh that keeps it
interesting it also
sort of helps in breaking up the um the
monotone
um the sort of style of a Blog yes so
use different content Styles use
different formats use different visuals
to keep your content alive and
interesting another common element for
all blog posts is you need to cater to
the different learning styles
some people may read want to read
text-based blog posts some people may
want to see more visual content or
infographics some people may want to see
video content yeah so over that Variety
in your blog posts so you can cater for
different type of audiences with
different type of learning styles and
then very important with a Blog and each
blog post sort of caters for that it
showcases your Authority
Yeah by offering different types of blog
posts you can demonstrate that you're
the expert regardless the type of blog
post that you do but people will come
back to your blog if they see you as
yeah this person knows what he's talking
about and that can help you build
credibility with the readers and
establish a yourself as a thought leader
in your industry yes so overall offering
a variety of different types of blog
posts can help you attract readers but
not only that you can retain your
readers and you may get them back they
may become part of your audience as long
as you showcase your expertise and keep
your content fresh and interesting
so given those common elements of blog
posts let's look at some different types
of blog posts the most popular blog
posts are list based posts yeah they
provide a list of tips of resources or
other information on a specific topic
people love lists people love the top
five things in this or 10 things you may
have missed yeah a really good example
of a list based post is life hacker live
hacker gives you life hacks yes so nine
food labels that don't mean what you
think they mean yeah 15 ways to build a
better breakfast sandwich mine of the
most dangerous driving and emergencies
little tips list of tips people love
those and the way they are presented on
this blog is actually quite interesting
yeah instead of having a long article
about this they actually have a short
introduction but they do them as
slideshows why not yeah it's visual
yeah so here is one yeah so here is the
next slide yeah so black eyes here you
see little highlight of what is uh what
what it's about yeah animals in the road
the next one is a car with mattress
flapping on the rooftop may look funny
but you don't want to be behind it yes
so lots of good tips and people love
these type of blogs
the next one is thought leadership posts
so they express the author's thoughts or
feelings on a specific topic and
particularly for businesses these are
very important because by building
thought leadership
which means being seen as an expert in
your field you're also building trust
now one of the best thought leadership
blogs in the industry is Harvard
Business review
yeah so lots of articles on a lot of
different topics around business yeah
here you see the different categories
the different media formats yeah and
here you see the different blogs that
they're topic writing about yes so
generative AI can help you tailor
messaging here is the article yeah and
here you see also the call to action
that we talked about subscribe to
Harvard Business Review yeah they have
here options to monetize the uh the blog
and here you talk about subscribe yeah
subscribe all simple call to actions
here is a summary of the article is the
article itself we talked about that
here's the social sharing button yeah
here's the visual that they use so all
the aspects that we talked about earlier
are available in this blog
yeah but these are typical thought
leadership blogs that can really help in
developing yourself as an expert
case study blogs they are sort of
blocked with articles that give an
in-depth analysis of a single topic
yes so
so typically to prove a point or back up
an argument yeah so this is kind of
background information to make your
point so good example for that is
HubSpot
yeah so HubSpot is a marketing
automation system they have one of the
best blogs in the industry yeah where
they give lots of background information
on all the different social media
digital marketing topics that you can
find yeah so here you see how a home
page of a Blog can be organized that is
your featured post here you have more
featured posts you see it's very visual
here you have the last sort of blog
posts here you see last categories and
the blog posts call to action call to
action here yeah another category and
then to make it more exciting we'll add
videos to this page as well
yeah so good example of a case study
blog yeah and and a general blog in with
all the features that it needs you then
have video in audio blocks video becomes
more and more important as a Channel of
communication yes so start using video
we also have seen the growth of
podcasting start using audio Yeah and
use those as part of your blogging
strategy as well here's a good example
yeah that is SoundCloud now SoundCloud
is a website which is kind of the
YouTube for audio Yeah for for uh for
podcasts for audio files and here you
see their blog which a good mix of
news resources audio files blog posts
with text yeah and video files as well
so it's a perfect combination of all the
elements that we're talking about here
yeah so very important to use video and
audio blogs as well here are some more
types of blogs news jacking or news
posts they provide information on recent
events or developments in a specific
industry yeah so good news checking
hacking website is wired yeah
specifically focused on technology
yeah and it is a go-to place for the
latest news on technology
it's you see a very clear style you see
it on the visuals as well yeah and it's
again it is a new kind of portal yeah
which gives you access to all the blog
posts it doesn't really look like a Blog
it looks like a news portal and that is
particularly for news websites a very
common way of using a blogging platform
to create a news portal okay we're then
looking at infographics posts now you
may have heard of infographics they uh
are Graphics that simplify complex
materials with a chart graphs and
Graphics yep and you can do blog posts
around those as well yeah one of my
favorites and you should follow them on
Facebook for and on Linked In the visual
capitalist the visual capitalist has a
everyday they come out with a new chart
yeah or a new infographic on a
particular topic yeah so here you see
again infographic on the top 50 most
visited websites in the world
so here's the infographic and then here
is to text sort of the background
information about it yeah so here's the
visuals so you see Google yeah you see
YouTube Facebook Twitter so here you see
how that all sort of um how that
develops yes so with the text subscribe
to it
yeah so good visual comparison
so very powerful website so use those
type of websites use that type of way of
presenting your your information we then
look at how two posts they offer a
detailed instruction on how to do a
particular task yeah people love those
a good example of how to block is Seth
godin's block
yep where he has very simple design for
his blog but this is all about the
content so he has a story of the week or
his top 100 posts yeah so how to tell a
great story advice for outer how to be
remarket how to write an ebook how to do
permission marketing an email checklist
very down to earth simple how-to tips
when it comes to business very
straightforward very popular blog when
it comes to how to posts and then last
but not least a very powerful type of
blog is the guest Post Yeah so why would
you write on your own blog why can't you
be a guest blogger on somebody else's
post has lots of benefits from a search
engine perspective as well for the
author of The Blog because you have
other websites that recognize your um
your your expertise in your area they
invite you to write about that and
Google sees that as a high Authority
ranking signal for your search yeah good
example of a
um a guest post is Neil Patel who has
its own website has his own blog is
really well recognized as a digital
marketing expert yep and here he is
writing an article as a guest on the
HubSpot blog yep so very useful very
powerful way and very powerful type of
blog posts that you can that you can
write
okay so those are the different blog
posts so let's look at how you go about
creating a Blog there's a number of
steps that you need to look at first of
all you need to look at what is the CMS
or the blogging platform that you're
going to use
yeah it's a very important decision for
bloggers because there's seven several
sort of decisions that you need to make
here first of all you're going to look
at am I going to use a simple platform
which is often free to begin with or am
I going professional straight away so if
you're going simple yep then you can go
for tools like wordpress.com
or wix.com they will host the website
for you and those are the typical tools
that give you some basic functionality
in the free version you will have your
website up and running within five
minutes but then if you want more
functionality you pay a bit more
yep now or you want to decide to go
professional which means you're going to
go to a web hosting provider and you're
going to install your own website on
their servers yep and one of the most
popular platforms for that is
wordpress.org which is a different
version of Wordpress
wordpress.org yeah gives you a lot more
flexibility a lot more freedom a lot
more
plugins yeah but it is a bit more
complicated to set up
yep and there is some the WordPress
itself doesn't cost you any money but
the hosting will cost you money yeah the
questions that you need to ask yourself
whether you want to go simple or complex
are hey
um what do you want your blog to do do
you just want to get it for your sharing
your expertise or do you want to
monetize your blog yeah do you want to
run it as the website for your business
for instance what are your technical
skills do you have very limited
technical skills you may want to go for
a hosted version on wordpress.com or Wix
or Weeble yeah do you have sufficient
technical skills you may want to go for
the wordpress.org version which is the
hosted version you need to think about
your budget
yeah do you have budget to use a hosted
platform yep and of course you need to
look at the features of the platforms
that you use can you find yourself in
the features that you want to use for
that yeah so that is the first question
that you want to ask yourself where are
you going to host your website and that
is what blogging platform are you going
to use step two is you're going to look
at your domain name of course very
important that is the name of your
website the name of your blog it's a
unique web address that is identified
that identifies your blog on the
internet
yes so when you choose your domain name
make sure make sure it is memorable it
is reflective of your brand people
recognize it it's available on other
social media websites as well yep so it
hasn't been taken by other people on
Facebook or Instagram yeah and maybe use
your keywords that are relevant for your
blog so lots of things that you need to
do if you want to have a domain then you
can check on
um on sites like GoDaddy if the domain
name is available yeah then when you
have it you can then buy it and you
usually pay the register for a year over
two years if it's a very simple name
that hasn't uh that's that is not very
popular then it often costs you maybe
ten dollars if it is a more popular name
that hasn't been registered yet you may
pay more
okay so then you also need to think
about the extension of your domain is it
going to be a.com is it going to be a
DOT net is it going to be a DOT org or
is it going to be a country extension
like dot NL for the Netherlands yes so
um or dot FR for France common rule is
if you're targeting a local market take
the URL of the local market if you're
targeting a global market go for the.com
or the dot net but preferably the.com if
you're an organ a government
organization then you want to usually
stick to the dot org
then of course you will have checked the
availability of your domain and then
you're going to register the domain
yes so you provide your contact
information you pay a small or a large
fee depending on the popularity of the
name and then in your website your blog
setup you're going to connect the domain
to your blog so that means updating the
name servers in your domain's registry
account so it then points to your blog
Hosting account
yeah so a very simple uh or good
provider you can go to is GoDaddy
dot.com or dot Co dot UK and they give
you everything yeah so type the domain
that you want yeah they can help you
create your website they have different
types of services they do domain names
they do website and hosting and they do
email marketing they have really good
support
yeah so if you want to type your domain
so let's take a for instance
um do company ABC is going to be my
domain
yep and you see here company abc dot Co
dot UK is available
[Music]
yes so
um there is here's the company letter
you see if you want to use that one is a
premium name so here you see all the
different varieties on the name
yeah here basiccompany.com that would
cost you three thousand pounds because
it is a quite a popular name
yeah so it is available but
yeah value for money
okay so that is your
um choosing your domain name then you're
going to look at your hosting plan and
your hosting plan is very important you
will only select a hosting plan if you
go for a hosted
blog solution yeah so which you do with
wordpress.org for instance so basically
when you select your hosting plan you
buy a bit of storage space on the
servers of that hosting profiler and on
that spit of storage space you install
your website and then the service the
hosting provider will connect that to
the Internet so they provide technology
and the support to store and maintain
your website
yes so that is a very important part and
again you need to consider your budget
and you also need to consider your
website requirements you need to look at
the reliability and the speed and the
uptime yeah so a reliable hosting
provider they offer you high uptime
percentage and fast loading times that
is very important
yep and you need to very carefully look
at customer support yeah so make sure
they offer 24 7 support preferably with
a chat option because often you have to
wait a long time to get access and if
you have a chat option it's much easier
to get your
um to get your problems solved and a
very important part of your hosting plan
as well is your security yeah make sure
that there is a spam protection on your
website and also look at your https yeah
so get your SSL certificate for your for
your website
yes so now some popular hosting
providers you can look at include
GoDaddy Bluehost HostGator dreamhost
take the time to research them yeah and
evaluate each option and certainly look
at the customer reviews as well
next step is you're going to design your
blog yeah so once you've created or you
selected your hosting provider you're
then going to set up your blog and you
would install
wordpress.org yeah and then you're going
to create your website now the first
thing that most of those CMS yet
platforms will ask you is what theme do
you want to pick
and they have a whole library of themes
that you can pick and choose from
and there's lots of websites that allow
you to buy themes whether it's a
photography theme a health theme a a
business theme yep and then you can just
buy that theme install it in your
WordPress setup yep and then you
download the demo for it and then you
have your website the only thing you
have to do is change the content and the
visuals and your website is ready yes so
very important that you pick a very
powerful sort of theme you then can
customize the theme with your own photos
your own logo your own color schemes
your own options so you can make it a
unique look and feel you then add your
own images yeah you customize the header
of the website
so and then you can use custom widgets
small medial modules that you can add to
your website that do things like sign up
for my newsletter or
[Music]
um
what's it click on the RSS feed of your
website Etc and then often you can add
your own sort of HTML coding or css
coding as well to give your website
additional functionality a really good
place to buy themes are esteems
forest.net
yeah so there's a whole range of themes
you can say for instance give me an
entertainment themes here you see
entertainment themes could be
um yeah so you want WordPress
yeah for instance WordPress themes and
then you just pick a theme yeah you can
actually do a live preview of the theme
yeah and this is here see the demos
we want the uh no coding so take for
instance this one here taste the
difference and there you see immediately
how your website will look like
how your blog will look like
yeah so then you download the theme
install it on WordPress
download the demo and again then the
only thing you have to do is change the
text and the visuals yeah and some
design elements
so it's so easy there's not a single
line of programming that you have to do
these days yeah when it comes to your
web development and that is a big
concern that people have do I still have
to program no you don't it's all sort of
intuitive step five start creating your
content
of course when your blog is live when
your blog is up and running you need to
start creating content for your blog too
by writing posts adding images creating
Pages organizing your content using the
categories and the tags making it easier
for people to find now before you can
start writing your posts you of course
you need to know what you're going to
write about yeah what is your focus what
is your Niche what are your interests
what is your passion you need to do
keyword research around those topics
yeah so that gives you the ability to
um understand what your target audience
want to read about yeah use tools like
Google Keyword Planner and we've done an
earlier video on how to use Google
Keyword Planner to find relevant
keywords for your blog
create an editorial calendar very
important know that every week you're
going to do a blog post yeah so every
Monday you need to draft a post
Wednesday you want to publish it yeah so
look forward maybe write four or eight
blog posts in advance and then you are
ready for the next eight weeks then
start writing your first blog post yeah
that introduces the blog and introduces
your Niche create a Content strategy
have a visual strategy and optimize your
blog posts for search using the keywords
yeah and using the meta tags for your
blogs
so that is really important because
Google loves to show blog posts higher
up in the um in the search results now
remember it takes time quality content
takes time and efforts so take the time
to research your topics and make sure
that you write compelling and
informative blog posts and promote your
content on social media and other
channels so that drives traffic back to
your website
and then finally we're going to look at
how to share your blog very important
you need to promote your blog and you
need to track your performance yeah so
share your blog on social media
platforms
engage with your audience when they have
comments or when they give feedback use
email marketing to promote your blog
yeah collaborate with other bloggers or
websites in your Niche try to get those
blogging those guest blogging
opportunities and use paid advertising
to promote your blog
yes so it's an ongoing effort and it
requires consistent effort
yeah on the tracking side use Google
analytics so set up your blog with
Google analytics so you get information
about traffic about your audience and um
about your most popular pages and your
most popular blog posts yes so you can
track specific actions in Google
analytics so how many people are signing
up for the newsletter for instance
monitor your social media analytics how
popular are your blog posts uh the
Facebook post about your blog on Twitter
or on Facebook or on Instagram yeah look
at open rates click through rates and
regularly review your blog's performance
and adjust your strategy if necessary
yes so very important part don't keep
your blog a secret start promoting it
high and wide
okay so let's close the session with
some writing tips
first of all know your audience
understand who is your target audience
and what are they looking for in your
blog yeah we talked about customer
personas create customer personas for
your key audiences yep and you're
writing for them you're not writing for
yourself you need to hit the language
that resonates with your audience
be authentic write in your own voice let
your personality shine through don't
write Anonymous yeah people want to see
the writer the author behind the or the
um the uh the article
yeah make sure that you research your
topic because that will help you in
writing authoritatively and then when
you write authoritatively you provide
value to your readers
don't limit yourself to text use images
use videos to supplement your writing
make your blog visually appealing
it goes without saying edit proofread
prove read prove read there's nothing
more frustrating than typos in your blog
posts yeah make sure your writing is
clear it is simple it is polished and
there is no typos in there just copy
your blog text put it in a word
processor yep and then do a spelling
checker then finally be consistent
consistency is key to building your
audience and for your readers to come
back
yes so and be consistent in the timing
as well try to do it daily or weekly or
monthly but give that consistency to
your readers
and if you take all these things
together and you are passionate about a
topic then I'm sure you're going to be
successful with your blog now let me
tell you about simply lens postgraduate
program in digital marketing created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint with this program you
will learn everything from the
fundamentals of digital marketing to the
latest trends and techniques used by top
marketers worldwide you will explore SEO
sem content marketing social media
marketing email marketing and more this
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world if you're
looking to jump start your career in
digital marketing or take your skills to
the next level then simply lens
professional certificate program in
digital marketing is the perfect place
to start to learn more about the course
you can click the link in the
description box below in today's video
we are going to be talking about
WordPress we're going to show you how to
use word press what is WordPress what
are the skills you need to use WordPress
why should you use WordPress and in the
process I'll give you a Hands-On demo of
the basic functionality of Wordpress
as usual I am Mark campman I am your
digital navigator for this video and if
you like the video click the like button
if you want to subscribe to our Channel
don't forget to click the Subscribe
button and join our fantastic community
of interactive Learners on the simply
learn YouTube channel but before we
start let me share something else with
you first simply learn has a new program
together with meta to offer you a
professional certificate in digital
marketing it's a fantastic program it's
the officially official program together
with meta and it is the um if we'll go
into here into the website yeah you'll
see that it is done together with the
Purdue University with meta is the
official partner and there's also
involvement with marketing land and
search engine engine Journal so so that
is a fantastic digital marketing course
and what the real value is that you will
be qualifying for The Meta blueprint
certification and The Meta blueprint is
Facebook's famous or metas famous
certification for everything there is to
know about about Facebook so very useful
program I can highly recommend this
training to you
okay so that was a little side step
let's go back to the slides and let's go
back to the program so what we're going
to be talking about is first we're going
to talk about content Management Systems
WordPress is a Content management system
to develop a website but to understand
this how to use this it is important
that you understand the essence of a
Content management system we'll then go
into what is WordPress we'll look at the
two versions of Wordpress that are out
there we're going to look at WordPress
features and I'll give you a a brief
demo of the WordPress functionality
we're going to look at one competitor in
specific who is very trying very hard to
um to sort of bite into WordPress Market
leadership and that's a competitor
called wix so we're going to do a short
comparison between Wix and WordPress I'm
going to then show you how to install
WordPress and then once you've got it
installed how are you going to create
your website and then we're going to
close off today's session be having a
look at some advantages and
disadvantages right but let me give you
some facts of Wordpress first WordPress
was released in 2003 as a blogging
platform by a guy Matt mullenwick and
then his friend Mike little it was a
fork off of an older blogging platform
called B2 Cafe log and it included basic
functionalities like the ability to
create a blog post to manage commands
and upload images
yeah it grew in popularity and features
were added like plugins and custom post
pipes with lots of different updates
across the years in 2008 and to 2010 the
15th 2018 and then new features came
like a redesigned admin interface a
theme customizer and a block editor
which made it a lot easier to develop
your websites now where is WordPress
today it is the most popular CMS or
content management system in the world
over 40 percent of all websites on the
internet they use WordPress and it
continues to be one of the most the
largest community of contributors to any
CMS platform here are some other
WordPress stats WordPress Powers 40 of
the internet and is available in over
200 languages WordPress users they
publish around 70 million new blog posts
and 77 million new comments each month
and yoast SEO which is a plug-in for
search engine optimization for your
website on WordPress has been downloaded
over
372 million times as of today makes it
one of the basically makes it the most
popular WordPress plugin that you can
can use the WordPress Community consists
of over 78 million active users and over
1.5 billion monthly unique visitors they
visit the WordPress websites without
knowing that of course
wordpress.com which is a separate
version of Wordpress and I'll come back
to that in a um in a minute they host
over 5.5 million active websites and
automatic which is the company behind
wordpress.com is valued at over 3
billion dollars and there's over 1500
remote employees across the world yeah
so some pretty staggering numbers and it
clearly makes WordPress the market
leader when it comes to a CMS or a
Content management system for your
website now what is a Content management
system before we dive into that yeah
cms's day started in the 1990s but they
were not widely used until the early
2000s so the early CMS systems were
often proprietary expensive and very
difficult to use
PHP nuke was like the first open source
content management system in 2000 later
followed by Drupal and Drupal became in
the ocean in those days one of the
leading development platforms for your
your website WordPress released in 2003
evolves into a fully fledged CMS and
currently is the most popular CMS for
any website out there other popular
cms's include Joomla launched in 2005
and Magento very much for e-commerce
website today's there are dozens of
cms's available both proprietary and
open source now so much kind of an
introduction on CMS let's define what a
CMS actually is a CMS also known as a
Content management system is like a very
friendly website building tool it is a
software application that provides a
hosted a centralized and organized
method for managing storing and
Publishing your website or any digital
content that you want to have yeah it
helps you create manage and publish
digital content without having to be a
tag or a wizkit or learn compare
complicated coding yeah so it's all
about ease of use it's about easy
content creation and management yeah
they make it simple for non-technical
users to create edit and manage website
content without requiring specific
technical skills or programming
knowledge it also provides much faster
website developments yeah because you
can use pre-built templates you can use
plugins and that all speeds up the
website development
yeah so that reduces the need to start
from scratch to start programming your
website from scratch you just pick the
building blocks and in the process of
doing that your website sort of comes
together it's also for improved Website
Maintenance yeah so a Content management
system they provide building tools for
Website Maintenance like updating the
software security for your website
backups for your website yeah and
optimization for search engines so it is
all about making your life a lot easier
so with his CMS you can use a simple
interface and you see that later when I
show you the web the the WordPress
backend yeah so you use a simple
interface to create and organize your
content design your website and manage
the different users and their
permissions who can work on your website
it also allows you to connect with other
tools like services to make your website
go even faster or e-commerce services or
Google services so they are designed to
be flexible they are designed to be
extensible yeah and one of the ways to
achieve this is by connecting the
various types of tools to your content
management system and by connecting to
databases cmss can store all data and
your content in a very effective way
now one of the big advantages of content
Management Systems is their open
architecture yeah so you can connect
what we call third-party apis to enhance
the functionality of your CMS
yep so you can add tools like Google
analytics or
um Salesforce HubSpot all tools through
the API you can connect you can connect
social media integration e-commerce
capability
Etc so it's a very open platform and
that makes them so interesting and then
one of the biggest assets of CNS cms's
and that's where WordPress is so
incredibly flexible you can have plugins
and extensions they are available which
can be installed to add features like
SEO contact forms image galleries
e-commerce you name it and you'll see in
WordPress there are thousands and
thousands of plugins for free or that
you pay for that gives you that added
functionality in in WordPress so in
general any website that needs to manage
and publish content on a regular basis
can benefit from a CMS
yeah because it can help you with
content organization it helps you with
Version Control with workflow management
user management and many other tasks are
essential for creating and managing your
website
so there are many types of websites that
can benefit from a CMS so take for
instance a standard block yes so with a
CMS for a Blog website it's easy to
create and publish your blog posts as
well as managing the comments and other
user generated content
yeah you have news websites
they sort of are a big aggregator of all
the news out there so for them it's easy
to create and manage blog posts as well
as they can help with the organization
and the management of the content
because they've got a huge amount of
news articles on their website and by
setting tags and by setting categories
you can give people easy access to that
content
e-commerce websites they can manage
product listings yep so that's what the
CMS can do for you managing product
listings manage pricing manage inventory
as well as tools to manage the orders
and the customer data
and corporate websites they can use a
CMS as well they can benefit from it so
it can include product and service
information news and events career
opportunities so basically every website
every type of website can benefit from
um from a CMS system
so as I said WordPress is one of the
leading CMS systems out there
so let's dive a bit deeper into
WordPress now bear in mind there are two
versions of Wordpress
there is wordpress.com
and there is wordpress.org
yeah wordpress.com is a hosted service
provider yeah that provides a simplified
version of the WordPress software
so you don't have to worry about hosting
it wordpress.com will host it for you
the only thing you do is to create an
account select a theme put in your
content press publish and your website
is live but it offers a limited set of
features themes and plugins so users
have limited control over the technical
aspects of their website but it is
really good for those people who want to
create a website quickly without the
hassle of any technical
complications or technical knowledge it
is literally go to wordpress.com create
an account select a theme add your
content press publish and your website
is live you don't need any longer
knowledge for that the basic version is
free of wordpress.com but as soon as
you're going to add additional
functionality like your own URL or
specific search engine optimization
features then you're going to pay a
premium fee but they're still not that
expensive
wordpress.org
is a CMS platform it's an open source
software that can be downloaded and
installed on your own web hosting server
and usually you go to a server a web
hosting server provider like GoDaddy or
Amazon or wherever you and you install
WordPress you basically hire a little
space on their server
yep and then you install WordPress and
then you have to develop your website
within that CMS so it's a self-hosted
solution and it gives you complete
control over the website's design the
website's functionality and the
customization options through
wordpress.org you have access to
thousands of themes thousands of plugins
and you can even modify the code of your
website if you would like that but you
are responsible for installing and
maintaining the WordPress software as
well as managing other things like
backup security hosting
Etc but it gives you flexibility it
gives you customization and if you're
comfortable with that if you have your
basic technical skills and you're
comfortable with managing your own
hosting and server configurations then
WordPress is definitely the place for
you wordpress.org
right so when we're going to talk about
WordPress going forward in this
presentation I'm going to be talking
about
wordpress.org yeah so keep that in mind
I'm not talking about wordpress.com but
wordpress.org I'm going to talk to you
about how to set up your own WordPress
on your own hosted server provider as it
were
okay and we're going to go through that
process so wordpress.org again is free
software for creating your website and
your blog so it's a self-hosted solution
which means you need to find a web
hosting company and you need to install
it on their servers against you have
complete control over your design your
functionality your customization and you
can choose from thousands of themes and
plugins but again you are responsible
for the hosting and the security right
so keep that in mind so let's have a
look at basic features of Wordpress
there are three basic features it's the
themes the plugins and the widgets yeah
so the themes they control the
appearance of the website
plugins add new features and
functionality and widgets display extra
content or functionality in specific
areas on the website
yes so they are used to customize the
appearance and the functionality of your
website so die let's dive a little bit
deeper seems they are pre-designed
templates that change the look and the
layout of your WordPress website
yet they control the overall design the
color scheme the fonts that are being
used and style of the website and there
are literally thousands tens of
thousands themes available on the
website you can select them through
WordPress you can also go to website and
I'll show you later theme forest for
instance where you can just look at
other themes and you can just either
there sometimes are for free others
their premium so you just click on the
theme and you click install and it will
activate on your WordPress website
plugins are add-ons that extend the
functionality of a WordPress website so
they can be used for features like SEO
contact forms social media sharing
buttons e-commerce functionality they're
very useful and there are estimate we
saw with the the themes there are
thousands and thousands of free and
premium plugins available in the
WordPress directory you can also use
your own theme or your own plugins but
you have to be careful with your plugins
because WordPress updates regularly to a
new version
yeah but you need to make sure that your
plugins are compliant with the new
updates so from from WordPress and
sometimes if your plugin provider is not
updating the plugin in line with the
WordPress updates then your plugin may
stop working and that may dysfunction
your your website widgets are small
modules that can be added to a sidebar
of a website or a header or a footer so
it gives you extra functionality or
extra content in that particular section
so you can have a search bar recent post
categories text social media icons or as
ads that you can have most themes bear
in mind they come pre-built widgets
included and users can also create your
own custom widgets
so let's look at three examples of
popular websites built on WordPress so
you get a bit of an idea
yes so the first website
that people may be surprised throughout
is the Walt Disney Company
yeah so this is a you see a huge company
a global Corporation they use a
WordPress CMS to to sort of build their
entire website yeah so it's all that's
the beauty about content web about
WordPress it's basically a a container
for the huge amount of content that you
have on your website
yeah and you see that here in the new
section that is where all their articles
are featured like blog post basically
and you can access them through the um
the the website
okay so that is the Walt Disney Company
so it's a very user-friendly design very
easy navigation and it's great way to
find all the information about the
company TechCrunch is another one it's a
leading technology website that covers
the latest in Tech news for star and
startups it's built on WordPress and it
features a responsive design that looks
great on both the desktop and the mobile
yeah so it includes a mix of Articles
videos podcasts and it allows users to
easily Browse by topic or search for
specific articles now what is a
responsive design a responsive design is
very important a responsive design means
that your website will automatically
resize to the device that the user is
using yes so it's basically it's a
mobile version mobile friendly version
of your website and when you pick a
design you always need to make sure that
the design is responsive and the best
way to test is if you make the website
smaller that it will automatically
resize and you can see that here you had
resize ultimately to the mobile formats
so the third example was Star Wars It's
the official Star Wars blog yeah it's a
fan sites that cover all things related
to Star Wars from movies TV shows to
books and comment comics
it's built on WordPress and it features
a design that reflects the Star Wars
Universe complete with their custom
fonts and background it includes News
interviews fan content as well as a
forum where users can discuss here in
the community where users can discuss
their favorite Star Wars topics yeah so
that's an example of three WordPress
websites yep so
that's uh that's it yeah so let's have a
look at the backend system of Wordpress
to get an idea what sits behind this
website so if I go to my own website and
that is react for Russia yeah that is a
um a kind of a how should I have in in
Marrakesh in Morocco that I rent out
that people can it's on Airbnb but
um besides that this website is built on
WordPress now a very easy way to find
out if a website is built on WordPress
is basically after the URL you just type
WP hyphen admin yeah that is what you
need to access
the backend it will ask you for a user
ID and a password
if the website if the the browser comes
back with URL does not exist then you
know that this website has not been
built on WordPress
okay so let's wait till we get the
access
oh I've already logged in yeah so that's
why we don't see uh the login screen
um but that's okay yeah you'll get first
a login screen you sign in and then you
get to your uh your dashboard so here
you see your WordPress the dashboard you
see the theme that I used yep and then
here is some updates that are required
at a glance how many posts how many
pages I can add a quick article
Etc but here you see on the left you see
the menu
yes so you see basically the most
important ones are your blog posts
are your website pages
yeah so WordPress works with pages and
posts pages are static Pages like your
home page
yeah posts are blog posts
okay so that's the basically the essence
of the structure of Wordpress then here
you see your themes
and then here you see your plugins
yep and then you have tools you have
your setting I've set up SEO on the site
I've set up Google analytics yes if I go
to my pages
and look at all pages
then here you get a list of all the
pages that you have active on your
website
okay so go to posts and you get a list
of all the posts that you have on your
website
the blog posts if you want to add a new
post you just click here add new if you
want to add a new page you can also
hover over the pages and then click add
new
you can add different things like
portfolio
or testimonials or products or Services
yeah and here is your media library this
is where you have all the photos and
videos that you have that you use on
your website
okay and here you have your theme
options so I selected a specific theme
and then here you see all the things
that you can change on your theme
so nothing to program yeah you can just
go through all these items and select
the um the specific options for that
section so you have the side layout the
header style
Etc
yes so that's the theme options
so these are all the options that you
can specify
and then here you have your appearance
so here you see the themes and you also
see the widgets and you can also specify
the menus
so when you start your website the first
thing
WordPress will ask you go to the themes
and then it will come default with two
or three themes
but you can
search for themes as well so you see
there are virtue there are probably a
handful of themes that I've got here
yeah but icon these are sort of
available I can also search for new
themes
okay so I can search here in WordPress I
can also search on outside WordPress in
a theme forest for instance and then
bring in the the theme into WordPress
okay so those are the themes here are
your widgets
you see a list of widgets that you have
available
yeah so here you see the widgets that
I've installed and where they are in the
sidebar the home Widget the footer
column yeah we have four footer columns
and here is the available widgets that I
can add
okay and then very important here is
your page with plugins I can search you
my installed plugins or can or I can add
new plugins so go to the install plugins
and then you see what plugins are you
have installed
yep and then you can add new plugins as
well
so that is a bit a very high level
overview of the WordPress functionality
I just want to leave it at this
um
it's important to understand yeah if we
go back to this the features if you want
to sort of summarize them
the one big benefit of Wordpress in the
features it is a very user-friendly
interface
it's a very intuitive interface yeah and
it makes it easy for users to create and
manage content on the website
the second big Advantage is the wide
range of customizable themes and
templates that you can select from that
is that's where WordPress is
second to num the availability of the
themes now there is a bit of a drawback
here I just want you to be aware of that
yeah if you are a WordPress expert if
you know WordPress quite well you will
see that a lot of the themes they have
kind of the same structure yes so I can
kind of recognize if a website is built
on WordPress or not yeah because the
themes are rarely
um fairly sort of similar but they
differ by the look and feel of them so
keep that in mind
yeah always very important make sure
that the website is adaptive yeah it's
responsive and that is another big
advantage of Wordpress that it has a
responsive and a mobile friendly design
another big advantage and the features
of plugin is their extensive of their
extensive plugin and widget architecture
yeah and that gives you a tremendous
library of functionality that you can
use on your on your website
because of these plugins you can also
very easily optimize your website for
SEO so WordPress has built-in features
for that but one of the best SEO plugins
is yoast SEO
where you can add meta tags site Maps
permalinks descriptions page titles
Etc
and then finally the features in
WordPress they really stand out when it
comes to supporting multi- languages
yes there was multiple languages making
it easy to create and manage websites
for international companies
and then to close very good features are
around the e-commerce with plug games
like woocommerce WordPress can power any
e-commerce website and can handle
transactions Inventory management and
and more
besides that the core engine of
Wordpress is its blogging platform
yes so it's still one of the best
blogging platforms but it is now also of
course past the capabilities to build
your entire website around it but the
blogging capabilities they include
posting post scheduling commenting and
social media sharing
WordPress also offers a fantastic
library for media management yeah so
making it easy to upload store manage
all types of media files like images
audio video PDFs and what have you
and to close the feature list off there
is a very strong Community around
WordPress very large very active for
Developers for designers and users they
contribute to the ongoing development of
Wordpress they provide support they
create themes and plugins to extend the
functionality and if you have a problem
I'm sure you can find an answer in the
WordPress Community because other people
will have experienced those problems as
well
okay now let's compare WordPress with
the competition
and I'm going back now to wordpress.com
and wordpress.org
yeah I remember wordpress.com was the
basic
um where WordPress would take care of
the hosting
yeah so you just open an account and
publish your site so competitors with
wordpress.com are Wix webflow
Squarespace bubble Soho sites
Square online which was formerly Weebly
I really like Weebly by the way and odoo
website builder if you look at
competitors for website wordpress.org we
look at HubSpot CMS Hub progress
sitefinity Drupal Joomla kentico
contentful and if you look at e-commerce
competitors we look at Shopify ionos
Squarespace volusion and big Commerce
now one of the big competitors
although they are indeed hosted
um
section yeah they are in the
wordpress.com section but they are
trying to eat in WordPress market share
in the
um the the wordpress.org section is wix
yes so although Wix provides hosting as
part of its own platform
WordPress and we'll be talking about a
comparison of Wix with wordpress.org
requires users to pay for the hosting so
keep that in mind
so Wix has been around for quite a few
years
and it was initially you just go to Wix
yeah you like wordpress.com you create
an account and you select a theme you
add your content click publish and your
website is live
where Wix stood out where they were
truly unique was on the quality of their
designs of their themes
yeah they were clearly a level higher
better quality than the WordPress themes
now in the early days one of the reasons
why Wix was so so powerful and so so
popular was because of the quality of
its themes
yeah and that that's where it really
stood out from WordPress now one of the
reasons why these themes stood out was
that they were developed only Jaffa
yep and with Java you have a lot more
flexibility on creating really nice kind
of themes but the problem with Java was
that Google couldn't index pages that
were built with Java because it was very
proprietary coding the text was kind of
buried in the code
so in the early days Wix had a very poor
reputation when it came to search engine
optimization
over the years that has changed Wix is
now no longer using Jaffa because Java
is is gone yeah but still there is this
sort of negative connotation with Wix is
not good for search engine optimization
but those are
um yeah as you know these things they
Linger on
so wix
because it is hosted
yeah so Wix has a more limited set of
templates and Designs available
because they are coming from Wix as it
were
yeah where WordPress is highly
customizable with thousands of plugins
and themes available
yeah so you got to understand that so
Wix is kind of closed where WordPress is
open
now there is another element here which
is kind of a negative on WordPress
because WordPress is so open
with plugins and themes coming from so
many different sources it is also
slightly more vulnerable for spam and
for
um
attacks on your website
yeah where Works where Wix is more
protected now let's look at those
themes so if I go to uh
uh Wix so here you see Wix create a
website that means business
still very good themes yep so very easy
to start very friendly to set up I'm not
going to log in or get started I'm just
going to show you the if I go to the
creation and I'm going to the website
templates
yeah 800 plus designer made templates
and here you see a selection of the
different templates that you can have a
look at
yes so you can uh just click on the
template you can edit that means you can
turn it into your website or you can
view the template how it would look like
so let's look here on view and then see
a live version of what the website would
look like
as you see they look really good
usually there's a starting point click
State onto editing site so you see how
easy it is to make
if I go to Wordpress themes I showed you
how to find the themes on WordPress
yeah I can also go to a site like theme
forests
yep and then here you have a huge
library of 50
000 WordPress plugins
yeah at various prices you can get them
for free you can get them for premium
you just look at the the theme so take
for instance
um
total WordPress
responsive yes so here you see look at
the live preview
and then here you can see the different
demos that they have yeah so you click
here on the demo and then you see how
the demo would look like
and then you can buy the demo and then
install it on your
on your WordPress installation
okay so those are the themes
that are very important and that is
where
um Wix has a more limited set but very
creative WordPress highly customable
with thousands of plugins and thousands
of themes
so Wix is known for its ease of use
yeah so anybody can easily start a
website on Wix but remember you have
limited control over the technical
aspects of your website because it is
managed by wix
where WordPress
wordpress.org you have complete control
so although you need more technical
speak kills yeah it gives you complete
control over the design adding
functionality even coding the website if
you want to
so keep that in mind
as we said earlier as well Wix has more
limited set of SEO options
historically remember with the Java
format that they had yeah the you may
need to upgrade your plan on Wix to get
more SEO features where on WordPress
you have the most fantastic SEO plugins
like yoast SEO all-in-one SEO which
gives full SEO functionality on your
website and we all know how important
SEO is
right now let's look at how we're going
to install WordPress
yes so there's two options
you can
do it through a hosting provider
yeah there are two options
there are two options you can be guided
by your hosting provider
or you can do it all yourself
so let me show you first how to do it
through your hosting provider
so here is my hosting provider which is
GoDaddy
yeah on GoDaddy I have multiple products
and one of my products is hosting
okay and I'll show you later the details
around that but when you go to your
hosting section in your service provider
yeah then here you have a list of the
websites that you are having installed
on the provider's server
if you want to add a new website which
is Guided by the hosting provider the
only thing you have to do is to go to
your admin panel
and in your admin panel you have all the
apps that you have access to
that could be email it could be file
manager it could be the images but
there's also apps that you can install
like WordPress or Magento or Joomla
so the only thing you need to do if you
want to install WordPress on your
hosting provider's server you just click
here on WordPress
that will then take you into a dialogue
yep and then you will just fill in the
details the name of your website the
user ID password yep and then it will
install it for you on your
um on your server so that's one way of
installing it
the second way of installing is do it
yourself
yeah and that's a bit more complicated
but these are the steps you will have to
go through first of all you need to
decide on what hosting provider you're
going to use that could be GoDaddy
Bluehost HostGator and what have you
then you go and actually download the
latest version of Wordpress from the
official WordPress website
then what you do you're going to upload
WordPress on your server that you have
with the server provider yep so you can
use an FTP client like filezilla or as I
showed you just now through your web
hosting control panel when word when go
dead Go Daddy does it for you yeah like
when your hosting provider does it for
you they create your SQL database if you
do it yourself you will have to create
your own mySQL database and your hosting
provider has an app for that
then you run the WordPress installation
script it will then create the WordPress
file and create a database and then you
can configure WordPress yeah so you log
into your admin area you choose the
theme add to plugins create pages and
you launch your site that is how easy it
is when you want to do it yourself okay
now back to the hosting provider for a
sec yeah it's important that you
understand if I go to GoDaddy
yeah then here you see the different
type of products that you have
so these are the products that I use I
have a section on domains so I have
bought domains that they manage for me
yep so here are my domains I have web
hosting
yeah so that is where I buy my slice of
their web server
yeah always make sure it has a cpanel
which is an admin the admin section
okay then very important make sure that
you buy web hosting and that you add SSL
certificates you may have heard of SSL
certificates they are the S between
behind HTTP yeah so https which is
basically a required security feature
that Google wants to see on your website
and then Additionally you can buy
website security
which is important and backups and
there's many other products but these
are the core products that you need from
your hosting provider okay so we are all
set up we have WordPress ready let's now
look at again at the website creation
so once you've chosen your hosting
provider and we talked about it you're
then going to install WordPress either
do it yourself or through your hosting
provider and then the first thing you're
going to do is choose a theme and I've
shown you the library of themes
yeah so there are free themes there are
paid themes that you can choose from and
you can also install custom themes
directly from a third-party developer
website and then you're going to
customize your theme what I like about
many of the themes they come with demos
and you can actually download the demo
so you see the full website completely
ready completely installed with the demo
and the only thing you have to do is to
change the content of the demo with your
own content
then you're going to add your logo
Etc you're going to add your own blog
post you're going to change your pages
upload to texting your pages yep and
then you're going to add plugins like
SEO like social media sharing and what
have you like forms and then you're
going to publish your website
yes so you can then publish it for the
world to see and share it on social
media and start promoting your website
once your website is ready what you
basically do you link your website to
your url
yep and that's the the hosting provider
can take it can can do that all for you
one important aspect on the hosting
provider make sure that you check the
service options from your hosting
provider if you have a technical problem
how good are they at responding and the
minimum you should look for is that they
have a chat capability
because there's nothing worse than
having to wait for a call when you call
them wait for half an hour or an hour on
the phone before you get an answer I
always prefer to do that through chat
right so what are the advantages and the
disadvantages of Wordpress
the big approach on WordPress are open
source customization large community
very SEO friendly and content management
yeah so it's the easiest CMS out there
and because it's open there are
literally tons of options to customize
it
if you have problems there is a huge
WordPress community that can help you
find the answers
if you want to do your SEO for your
website yeah WordPress has fantastic
plugins like yoast SEO all in one SEO to
actually
make the SEO as easy and as smooth as
possible for your website so the large
community is really helpful in WordPress
if you have any problems with your with
your website and with your WordPress
installation and of course the content
management is very important as you can
see as you saw on the demo is you can
really access the blog posts the pages
the media in a very friendly way so
there's lots of benefits in using
WordPress but there are some negatives
as well yeah and I think a big negative
is its open source positive yeah because
it's open source the security is
slightly more at risk as it were yes so
you're more prone to attacks and to spam
than
um on on closed platforms yep and as
well of course you do need some
technical skills yeah maintenance is an
issue as well yeah so and I mentioned
that earlier if you have an update on
the WordPress
um sort of the WordPress sort of a CMS
then your plugins need to be upgraded as
well and some plug-in providers they're
later with upgrading and it may happen
that plugins stop working after a
WordPress CMS upgrade so you need to be
very alert to those things and one final
issue that may come up with WordPress is
that they tend to be slightly slower in
in performance which basically means it
takes longer to load a page so you need
to be aware of that you need to track
that you need to measure that and you
can get tools in WordPress as a plugin
that can help you with improving the
speed of your website now let me tell
you about simply lens postgraduate
program in digital marketing created in
collaboration with Purdue University and
meta blueprint with this program you
will learn everything from the
fundamentals of digital marketing to the
latest trends and techniques used by top
marketers worldwide you will explore SEO
sem content marketing social media
marketing email marketing and more this
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in the digital marketing world if you're
looking to jump start your career in
digital marketing or take your skills to
the next level then simply learns
professional certificate program in
digital marketing is the perfect place
to start to learn more about the course
you can click the Link in the
description box below
r-o-m-i this may not be the term that is
bandied about inside your organization
it's certainly not a term that is
bandied about in the industry
but it's actually the one that you want
to use so let me explain
what is in it for you to measure this
this actually begins to position you not
as the company's next CMO it may
position you as the company's next CEO
because guess what the CFO is not the
top of the food chain
and the CFO has generally been asking
for the wrong thing for years
this is the right thing
to demonstrate this is the calculation
you want to do
this puts you in a powerful position
first of all you shift the conversation
you basically put yourself in a position
of convincing generally it's the CFO
that you understand Finance as well as
he or she does
and you know most CFOs aren't expecting
that from somebody in marketing you know
you know they tend to look down on us
we're we're merely the expense
you know that they have to deduct
somewhere along the way in their
financial calculations
okay fine but here's the deal
Roi is the wrong metric the CFO may ask
for it because the CFO is used to asking
for it for other kinds of things like
Capital expenditures
if you're going to do a capital
expenditure like building a new Factory
or a plant or you're going to stock a
lot of inventory someplace that's a
capital expenditure or what is known as
cap X
and trust me if you are a publicly
traded company some investor out there
some industry analyst is gonna wanna
know about your capex it's something
you're going to have to report on a
quarterly basis so trust me the CFO is
focused on it
but that kind of money is tied up
when you make that kind of investment
it's generally a long-term one and you
may depreciate it but you know what
that's why everyone's sort of focused on
it it turns out marketing is not a
capital expenditure
marketing is an expense you generally
expense it over the course of a quarter
you know we spent some money this month
on who knows advertising content
marketing Pizza on the blank
and if it is an operational expenditure
then it is called up X
and if you want to measure the impact of
what you're doing in marketing
you know you end up using a very
different formula than your CFO has been
asking for for years but here's the deal
when you look across the table and say
actually you're asking for the wrong
thing what you really want is Romi not
Roi
um and yeah I do know how to calculate
that
a return on marketing investment is
basically the incremental Revenue that
you can attribute to your marketing
so you know we've been measuring goals
or micro goals and you can measure those
in Revenue because you know what the
lead is that you brought in and what
it's worth and you know what the sales
you brought in and what they're worth or
you you certainly know what percentage
of those leads tend to convert to sales
and therefore you you gotta uh a figure
that what your sales pipeline may be
valued at
guess what you can calculate that
and then here's the magic you go beyond
Revenue
a lot of people would stop there and say
wow that's an impressive thing I've
never reported Revenue before aren't I a
hero now
but if you take the next step and you
say and also I know what our
contribution margin is
a lot of people will call that your
profit margin
in other words uh when you raise revenue
there's still a cost of goods sold
you know take some money to manufacture
your product or it takes some money
um you know that you for the people you
have to pay to deliver your service
and when you're all done paying uh you
know the cost of goods sold
what's left is your profit
and that is a percentage of your Revenue
and if you multiply the revenue that you
brought in times the profit margin so
some percentage of that is going to turn
into profit
and then you subtract what you've spent
on your content marketing campaign
and divide by what you've spent
you come up with a number it's your Romi
and let me give you an example just to
sort of bring this home let's say for
example
that you spent a hundred thousand
dollars on a Content marketing program
and it delivered five hundred thousand
dollars in incremental Revenue that you
have been able to track
and say didn't come in from outer space
you know here's the campaign we ran we
generated this
and oh by the way
the contribution margin for that 500 000
in Revenue was
let's say sixty percent in other words
it took about 40 percent to cover the
cost of goods sold but the profits on
top of that were sixty percent where
does that number come from it's a
mythical number but you know it's going
to vary in different organizations so
I'm just using it here to teach you the
math
but I'm going to measure my results by
taking that five hundred thousand
multiplying by sixty percent because I
want to get to the profit number
and then I'm going to subtract the
hundred thousand that I spent and divide
by the hundred thousand and I get the
number two
and you're going to say I've never heard
this number before
and the answer is neither has your CFO
but here's what it means
for every dollar that you spent on
content marketing
you generated two dollars
in profit
not Revenue you generated five dollars
in Revenue
you generated two dollars in profit
now do you want to do a little more
content marketing next quarter
let me tell you anything that is a
positive number is a good result if you
can get anything north of one
you're breaking even
greetings everyone this is Rob Sanders
with simply learn thank you for joining
and today we're going to cover content
marketing interview questions and
answers so thanks for joining again and
here's how it's gonna work so if you
have any questions to these questions or
answers feel free to just comment right
below this video and we'll get back to
you as soon as possible we're going to
go through a series of questions and I'm
going to answer those questions for you
starting out what are the essential
components of a good web content okay so
essential components okay so what do we
want our content to do well we want it
to be useful so web content should be
written in a way which caters to what
the reader wants okay so somebody's not
going to read your content if it's not
useful for them okay this because it
affects reader engagement okay so if
it's not interesting it's not useful
somebody's just not going to read it
plain and simple it also has to be
engaging so let listen even if it is
relevant to a user you still have to
write the content so it's engaging so
you want to add elements like imagery
videos hey you can even turn your
content into an infographic okay you
want to do something that's going to be
engaging for the user if it's engaging
they're going to read it and engage with
the content okay and then good content
should have some call to action so
content must be written in a way that
can drive call to action okay so if
you're writing a blog post you know I've
seen a lot of blog posts just simply
start and with good content but it
doesn't leave the user with anywhere to
go so have that call to action put some
internal links in that content give
somebody a place to go after they're
done engaging with the good content you
write okay so some other things to think
about some other components for good
content well credibility so you know
anybody can write what are you writing
about something you know what you're
writing about are you a good talking
point a good expert or have experience
about this content so you also want to
use you know information from a
legitimate Source okay so you don't want
to grab something in your and use it in
your content that's just not legitimate
because it does hurt your credibility
and the organization's credibility and
then also originality I mean write
something that nobody else has written
so obviously you don't want to
plagiarize because if you plagiarize and
there are tools out there where people
can easily just put their content in
there to see what else is out there see
if somebody else has plagiarized it so
it's very easy to find people who
plagiarize so don't be that person what
I would recommend create a good content
calendar and come up with some ideas
before you write them next question
related to content marketing so what are
the types of content you can create well
there are a lot of things you can create
start with the blog blog to me is always
a great place to start it's a blank
canvas for your your ideas your thoughts
your opinions okay that's a great thing
about a Blog it it accentuates
personality you can create a video
videos are always engaging you can
create an infographic infographics to me
or you know Hidden Gem instead of
somebody reading the same old same old
you're laying this out in a very visual
way that's easy to understand create a
case study okay so if you're you know
digital marketing expert you've done
social media for another client you know
write about it you know show the
successes show that you are an expert
show that you've created successful
campaigns and social and in the form of
case study you can create a white paper
white papers are a good educational
pieces you can also create an ebook Okay
ebook hey if you have a lot of content
you want to lay it out and ebook's a
good way to go and you have a lot of
choices here when it comes to content a
lot of choices okay so what are the
advantages of having a Content counter
so I alluded to that just a couple of
seconds ago so my let's really break
this down here because content counters
to me are so important well first of all
counterpart of content calendar allows
you to think about dates so if you're
planning something you're going to have
important dates in mind okay so content
calendar and almost ensures you don't
miss anything you know that's a good
opportunity for you to leverage like you
know Black Friday Cyber Monday you know
it's probably important you know when
those days are if you're in e-commerce
so that's why having a Content calendar
helps it helps you plan out your content
based on important dates or based on
dates that work for what you're trying
to do they also help because you could
stick to a consistent schedule okay so
if you don't have a Content calendar
you're probably just arbitrarily writing
content here and there well what if your
users crave and really engage with the
content they're going to want more
sticking to something consistent is
going to really get people to come back
for more they know when you're going to
post they're going to be waiting for it
and if it's every Tuesday morning at
eight o'clock hey post it Tuesday
morning 8 o'clock your users will get
used to that schedule and it does help
build up your following it does help
help build up your community and in the
end cultivates a long lasting
relationship and having a Content
calendar also allows you to mix up your
content okay so you can see and plan
ahead different types of content in
different formats that way it allows you
to mix it up okay whether it be a blog
post uh an infographic a video about
different topics okay some other
advantages here saving time it just
allows you to prepare for the future
when you can prepare you're efficient
and when you're efficient you're not
wasting time and so to me having a
Content calendar is a must because a lot
of us are busy who has time and
especially if you're going to work in a
new company let's say writing content
you definitely want to have a Content
counter because you're going to want to
use that time to efficiently plan this
is a new company you're going to start
working at you want to understand who
this company is what they've done in the
past what you haven't done and what you
want to do okay so all of that helps you
plan and prepare and it saves you the
time and effort and hassle down the road
and then at the end of the day you want
to be able to figure out what works so
planning your posts puts less strain on
you and your team members as well as
company resources because when you plan
and you post you're going to get data
and then when you get data it's either
going to work or not work and if it
doesn't work then you know in the future
you're not going to put that piece of
content or that topic in the content
calendar again it's that simple okay
some other advantages fresh content okay
so having a con content calendar allows
you to always keep content fresh again
you're going to be on a consistent
schedule and you're not going to be
writing about the same things over and
over again so it could be just simply
Twitter if you're putting a Content
calendar and together for Twitter well
you don't want to have the same tweets
every other day so it does ensure that
you're getting tweets out there that are
fresh that are new that are different
and again figure out what works a
Content counter makes it easier measure
results and optimize performance so you
always want to you know maybe put some
metrics in with your content calendar so
you can see side by side content
historically that is performed content
that is not performed okay so next
question you may get what type of
content Works in each stage of the
customer life cycle so you have
awareness engagement purchase post
purchase advocacy okay so let's break
these down here so awareness okay so you
want people to understand who you are
okay that could be a guest blog an
influencer helping you out it could be a
cold email a video that can potentially
go viral a social media post introducing
a product you have engagement so you
want people to engage with your content
what are you going to do to get people
to engage well you could certainly write
an email and have people open that email
and go to your website you can have an
ebook where people can actually download
and read it or you can have a Blog where
people can comment or landing page where
they can fill out a form submission you
have a valuation so with social media we
know there's a lot of Engagement going
on but when you're putting content out
there you can certainly open it up to
testimonials okay you can generate white
papers okay or you can generate case
studies case study is a good way for
companies to evaluate what you've done
in the past if you've worked in it for a
specific product in the past and it's
worked you certainly want to put that
out there for potential clients in that
same industry purchase trying to get
people to purchase what are you going to
do well you can certainly have landing
pages a nice you know website a nice
shopping cart with some nice content
okay onboarding emails get those emails
out there and get people to go back to
the website and purchase of course you
can have product and serve service
details as well meaning you know one one
page downloadable PDFs that describe the
product okay yeah post purchase okay so
people who've already purchased you
could certainly send out follow-up
emails and you can do blog roundups you
know give people an opportunity to see
what features or updates are happening
to the product okay of course case
studies of repeat customers or content
types that detail a new feature or
service okay so if somebody's already
purchased hey you may want to send them
some content of another product that
complements the product they bought so a
lot of things you can do to engage with
your user who's already purchased and
then advocacy you want people to help
you out here so have the user generate
the content you can have exclusive
discounts for your community they're
going to be your Advocates so give them
exclusive discounts and then pictures of
customers engaging with your products
okay who's not going to share that so
you're going to have people will share
that information in other words you can
generate content where hey people can
help you out here and be your Advocate
okay so how do you decide what topic and
subject to write on okay well going back
to the content counter that always
counts you to see what you've put in
that content calendar but there are some
other methods you can use and you could
certainly identify your target audience
and not only identify your target
audience but what their needs are okay
so you can write content based on
audience you could certainly do some
research with keywords okay what's
trending what keywords are not trending
okay and right around what's trending
for example okay you could certainly
take a look at social media for example
quora I always look at quora Cora's
interesting entertaining informational
hey people are certainly having
conversations on Quorum and you can
certainly analyze those conversations
because they certainly get in depth and
you can decide hey do I want to write a
topic around something that really just
won't go away in terms of conversing
core is a good example of analyzing
conversations they tend to be a little
bit more in depth so some other things
you could do you can look at your
competitors and what kind of
conversations are happening on your
competitors blogs or your competitors
social media platforms and Pages you can
keep track of blogs and articles from
subject matter experts commentators
critics and so on okay so you can get
ideas from them another question you may
get which is very important if you're
going to start working for a company you
need to understand the tone the tone of
your content because that is going to
fit and be in line with the company
you're working for okay so you're always
going to have a brand personality so the
characteristics of a brand are the
guidelines based on which the content
strategy is developed the tone of the
content must align itself to the content
strategy your audience profile so you
got you need to determine who your
audience is okay and how the brand wants
to be seen by that audience so you know
if you have an older audience you're not
going to use younger audience I.E street
lingo or today's lingo and and the
younger generation uh you're going to
use you know language that's going to
fit the audience you're talking to and
then of course the channel itself so the
content you create must be irrespective
of the channel consistent with brand
attributes okay so you gotta pick and
choose the channel if it's LinkedIn for
example hey you know linkedin's more
business oriented okay so you're not
going to be you know as humorous as you
would be say on Instagram or Facebook
all of these have one thing in common
again that's brand guidelines you have
to stay within the brand what is the
Brand's personality how do we want to
talk to our audience and what platform
are we using to talk to our audience how
do you promote your content once it's
live well that's always a good question
hey you doing the the work the putting
in the hard work to create this you know
it could be a video and videos take a
long time it could be an infographic an
e-book okay so send it out via email
okay if you haven't an email list send
it out and let people know this
content's there put a link in the email
or or even a piece or snippet or preview
of the content in the email so you're
using the email to broadcast and
encourage people to you know if it's an
ebook get the rest of the ebook Okay you
can certainly leverage social media to
engage with your community that's the
best you know just as good as email get
out there and let people know hey I got
I got my book published come and
download it you know you can give a
discount to the first 100 people that
download it okay you can always promote
your content via ads so whether that be
Google or Facebook you always have an
opportunity to meet more prominent by
advertising the content that you have to
offer so you can always reach out on
social media again targeting interesting
people directly so you can always
interact with people on social or you
can write for others attract people from
the web to important pages of your
website by guest posting so you can
always go on to a popular blog post and
write something and you know link it up
or or have it be relevant to the content
you've written so next question how can
you determine how well your content is
doing okay very important again you've
done all the work you've put the content
calendar together you got the content
ready to go it's published you're
promoting it social email guest blogging
but you want to determine how it's doing
well depends on the channel really is
what it comes down to so if it's organic
search you want to be able to see if
it's ranking for the keywords you
optimize that content for if it's social
you want to be able to see if you have
engagement shares comments Etc of course
you can always look at analytics and see
how much traffic that blog post is
getting or that page with the white
paper is getting okay so you can always
look at your analytics and look at the
traffic okay and again you can always
look to see if there are conversions in
the form of an inquiry or lead or sale
so at the end of the day you want to
align the content with the channel and
you want to align the kpi with the
content and channel okay so if it's
social you're not likely going to get
conversions unless you're doing paid ads
if you're posting organically on social
then you're probably going to get some
engagement so you have to align the
right metric with the right channel what
are the steps involved in the content
marketing process okay so you really
need to decide what goal you want to
achieve with the content marketing
campaign so that goes back to what I was
just saying a minute ago if you have
content you post it on social then
what's the goal what are you trying to
achieve well you're probably going to
get engagement and likes you need to
Define buyer personas to determine the
audience best suited for your content
okay so you're always writing for an
audience and you're going to Market that
content for for that audience so you
always got to keep that in mind okay run
content audience to the audits to
determine the best type of content that
can be used in other words how did it
perform what kind of Engagement did you
get with the infographic or did that
video really really perform well or do
we want to use you know a blog post next
time around or an image next time around
so continuing on here you want to choose
an appropriate content management system
okay so how are we managing all this
content okay is it WordPress or is it
another platform okay you could start
brainstorming for ideas for new content
so again that goes back to the content
calendar you leverage your content
counter to always create ideas for new
content okay then you want to settle on
a particular type of content that you
want to create okay so once you come up
and you're managing your content you've
come up with some ideas then you
obviously want to choose the format and
then of course you want to publish and
manage your content after it's all said
and done so these are the steps involved
again just quickly decide on the goal
the kpi decide on your audience look at
what's worked and not worked in the past
get your content set up in the platform
okay we'll get the platform ready to go
I should say Okay generate ideas with
that content count or I ideally go to
the content calendar for the ideas
choose that type and then publish and
manage and when I say manage I mean
again going back to analytics or going
back to the kpi that you align with that
content to see if it's performing or not
okay so next question here how do you
target the Right audience for your
content it's a very good question you're
not writing content for everyone let's
be honest here so you have to collect
demographics of your target audience
based on who's coming to your website
based on who subscribed to your emails
based on who's following you on social
media so in other words words you have
people interacting with you okay in
different channels and you need to
understand who these people are so or
they fit a certain age range or
generation are they skewed more female
to male education level what's their
Affinity or interest okay do they have a
certain income so you need to really
break down your audience here and you
could do that in analytics you could do
that on social you can do that just by
looking at your email list okay the all
those will paint a picture as to who
your audience is and this was all for
this content marketing full course hope
you guys found it informative and
helpful if you like this session then
like share and subscribe if you have any
questions then you can drop them in the
comment section below thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign